good evening everyone this is a meeting
planning and development management
committee of trafford council
my name's councillor ben hartley i'm the
vice chair of the committee
with us this evening we have members of
the committee who are all local
councillors i'll i'll introduce them as
they speak on items
also with me on on my left and my right
are officers from the council from the
planning team the highways team and the
legal team
item one on the agenda is attendances
and apologies for absence i've had
apologies from the committee chair
councillor williams and councillor acton
uh grateful to you for
um stepping in as a substitute member
any other apologies from anyone
[Music]
i think everyone else is here so we'll
go on to item number two which is
declarations of interest so members to
give notice of any personal or
prejudicial interest and the nature of
that interest relating to any item on
the agenda in accordance with the
adopted code of conduct are any members
wishing to declare an interest in any of
the items
now okay move on uh item number three is
the minutes to receive and if so agreed
to approve as a correct record the
minutes of the meeting held on 14th of
april 2022
uh i don't think i was here so uh could
i have a member willing to move
councillor thomas and uh councilwoman
stanley to second so those minutes are
approved
actual number four questions from
members of public so we have a maximum
of 15 minutes allocated to public
questions
submitted in writing to democratic
services by 4 pm
2 working days prior to this meeting
questions must be within the remit of
the committee or be relevant to items
appearing on the agenda and will be
submitted in the order in which they
were received
um we do have a question i believe is mr
ning with us
deceit
okay so we've had a question submitted
by remember the public so i think um
miss carly's going to read the question
and then also the answer to that
question
i am yes thank you chair
um so this is a a question from uh mr
ning of five cherton avenue in sale
a statement of concern that the planning
process fails to monitor applicant
compliance planning performance was last
published in september 2013
recent restructuring of the planning
compliance team and increased levels of
commercial and personal property
development suggests a policy of
self-validation and self-compliance
including required inspection of
building work
there is a request for an update of
planning performance including permitted
developments appeals and variations
there is a request for a call-in
of 103-760-hha
21 and related 107-572-var
22 as an example of poor self-validation
and self-compliance
and before i read the statement i'm just
going to confirm to the committee that
the call-in request has been directed
back to him to go through the ward
councillor as is as is appropriate
one of those applications can't be
called in because it has been determined
but he has been given the the advice on
how to do that um through through the
correct procedure
in terms in terms of the question then
the statement in response is as follows
traffic council recognises the value of
a professional proactive and
well-resourced planning enforcement
function and we have recently
restructured the planning service to
increase our specialist capacity in this
area
there is more development taking place
in the borough but this is reflected in
increased numbers of planning
applications being submitted
the council typically receives around
400 planning enforcement complaints per
year which require investigation
a large proportion of these complaints
relate to house extensions and
allegations of non-compliance with
approved plans or exceedence of
permitted development tolerances
in many of these cases we find that
there is either no breach of planning
control or that the unauthorized
development can be regularized through
an application for an amendment
variation or retrospective permission
the number of complaints we receive
indicate that residents are vigilant in
monitoring development in their
neighborhoods and that they are not
afraid to report their concerns to the
council
a programme of proactive monitoring or
verification of compliance with
householder planning applications would
require significant additional resource
but is unlikely to be any more effective
in identifying non-compliance than
monitoring by residents
unlike building control there is no
statutory inspection regime for planning
it is ultimately a homeowner's
responsibility to ensure that they
comply with planning legislation when
extending their home
there is also no requirement for a
homeowner to notify the planning service
if they are carrying out works including
extensions which do not require planning
permission unless those requests
specifically fall under the prior
approval regime
the service have identified areas where
a more proactive approach can be taken
by officers including monitoring of new
housing developments advertisement
control and untidy or derelict sites
we will shortly be advertising for a new
enforcement officer to increase our
capacity and capability for delivering
these proactive interventions
in respect to planning performance a
range of data is published quarterly and
annually for all local planning
authorities including trafford by the
government
the most recent return is for quarters
one to quarter three twenty twenty one
to twenty two i.e between the first of
april twenty twenty one and the thirty
first to december twenty twenty one
the data for quarter four is still being
validated
the government monitors local authority
planning performance and can put
authority in special measures if it is
not performing adequately
in quarters ones to quarter 3 20 21 22
100 of major applications were
determined within 13 weeks for an agreed
extension of time
85.7 percent of minor applications and
79.8 percent of other applications which
are mainly householders were determined
within eight weeks or an agreed
extension of time
in respect of appeals 50 appeals were
determined by the planning inspector in
2021-22
of which 34 which is 68 were dismissed
only one of the seven appeals determined
so far in 2022 to 23 has been allowed
specific data for permitted development
and variation applications is not
collected by government as this is not a
reflect 2021 on the 31st of march 2022
132 applications for householder prior
approval was submitted where a scheme is
permitted development subject to
conditions being satisfied and approved
by the planning authority
283 certificates of lawful development
with certificate was submitted which
confirmed that planning permission is
not required
74 variation of condition applications
were submitted of which 20 were for
household development thank you chair
[Music]
thank you miss curley for the question
and the answer and item number five on
the agenda is the additional information
report uh which was emailed to members
today and copies are available i i
believe so that uh is for noting as we
consider the the applications for
permission to develop which is item
number six which we'll move on to now so
it's to consider the attached reports of
the head of planning and development for
the following applications um
and before i move on to the applications
i'll just maybe explain the process
that we'll follow on each application
for the people
in the room and also anybody anybody
watching from home
so for each of the items uh we'll first
of all receive a presentation from a
member of the of the planning team
you'll be able to hear and see that
presentation
um on some of the items we'll then have
speakers against the application and
also in favor of the application we have
residents speaking and also local war
councillors speaking on items
residents will usually be given three
minutes to address the committee
and when you get to the end of that
three minutes i'll ask you to conclude
your remarks award councillors will will
be given five minutes to speak on items
once we've heard from those speakers uh
i'll then open up the discussion to
members of the committee and i'll
introduce them as they speak
um members of the committee will will
discuss and can then propose and also
second motions that we
agree with the officer's recommendation
in the report or that we oppose that
that recommendation those motions have
to be proposed and seconded by members
of the committee
and will then vote on those motions uh
and the vote will be uh by a simple
majority and you'll be able to see us
voting and the vote will be
noted and recorded
um at certain times during some of the
uh some of the discussion i may ask for
advice from planning officers or or
legal officers who are or with us in the
room with any points are
uh raised um
final thing that i've admitted to
mention is once the committee are
discussing the agenda items the
discussion is amongst the committee only
so i'm afraid we can't engage in
questioning of any residents or ward
councils who come to speak to us
good okay we'll take the applications in
the order in which they're listed in the
agenda so the first application we'll
look at is number 103
905 24 bonneville chase in altering them
and we'll start that's on page one of
the bundle that committee members have
and we'll start off with a presentation
from mr day thank you
thank you
okay yeah um
this application has been reported to
the planning and development management
committee as more than six objections
have been received contrary to the
officer recommendation
um the application relates to a detached
property on the cul-de-sac at bonneville
chase
in altingham the property is located at
the end of the cul-de-sac
and the rear boundary is shared with
dunham forest gulf and country club
the entire site is included within tree
protection order tree preservation order
076
brad gate road bonville road
the application proposes a two-story
front extension
a part two-story part single-story side
extension
and a single-story rear extension with a
roof terrace
one protected tree would be removed as
part of the works
left objection being received from seven
neighboring properties
on the grounds of design loss of
spaciousness
impact on residential immunity
and impact on trees
[Music]
i'll just quickly run through the slides
so you can see the the location of the
site there at the end of the cul-de-sac
um
uh that's the
the site layout showing the extensions
in the diagonal hatch
ground floor existing and
proposed plans
and first floor
um the existing elevations
and existing side elevations
and proposed elevations showing the
alterations to design on the front
elevation
with the changes to the windows and the
slightly higher cables
and then the rear elevation showing the
flat roof rear extension at the rear
on the side elevations
um
and some photographs of the site this is
the front of the application property
and again the front just viewed from
slightly further away
um at the highway
the rear elevation of the application
property
um the boundary with um
number nine bundle chase
uh the side boundary with number 22
and then the last two slides are
photographs that have been sent in by
the objector at number 22
showing the view from their
windows
closest to the development looking
towards the application property
and obviously you can see the tree
that is proposed to be removed within
that photograph
thank you
thank you mr day we have
speakers both against and for this
application
so we have uh councillor wetton and
mr healey um have you decided between
you who'd like to speak first come to
the wetton you want to
come up to the table and
i know you've been here many times
before
[Music]
so you'll have um five minutes to speak
to us and we'll start the clock once you
start speaking with councillor wetton
thank you
good evening and thank you for this
opportunity
this application is one that is beset
with devil in the detail
in the first place the application form
that was submitted failed to point out
that a protected tree is affected by the
proposals
and that a protected tree would need to
be removed as part of the project
thus that issue had to come out
in the wash
the urban forestry group report a late
representation contains vital details
about that tree an oak tree so called t1
that report is very worthy of
consideration
not least because a beautiful tree might
depend on it
it's very different assessment of the
tree provided by an arboriculturist
contrasting with the applicant's tree
report
which is surely written as a means to an
end to get rid of a protected tree to
extend the house
the planning history in the report the
main report refers to a previous
application and sets out details as to
why it was refused
these details must surely apply to this
application
examining the plans for that refused
application shows the right-hand side of
the extension coming forward and
encroaching on number 22
yet nowhere near as much as the plans
that are before us today
that application was refused
with these proposals the distances
between the first floor windows of the
proposed development and the bedroom
windows of number 22 are totally
unacceptable
and i think that exactly demonstrated in
in the report in the late
representations
two very deep front bedroom
front windows bedroom windows
overlook the bedroom windows of number
22.
even allowing some tolerances for angles
the distances are too close the
proximity is unacceptable
and let's be frank conditioning a front
elevation bedroom window to have opaque
glass
is an admission that the extension is
too close to its neighbors
quite how it would look i don't know
look like somebody winking at the rest
of the street
it is that proximity to number 22 which
draws the tree t1 into the argument the
tree is protected
but the overwhelming expansion of these
proposals creates threats to the tree
no doubt that is where the tree's
condition gets rubbished by the
applicant's tree person yet most
strongly defended by a new report
supplied in the late representations
try as i may i could not find a back
report with this application
to my relative cost recently i found out
how integral a bat report can be to
applications
the comments on bat reports in the late
representations do not quite chime with
my previous experience
so we know that bats inhabit the
immediate area there are regular
sightings the proposals
would see an important tree lost one
that bats may roost in
further the proposals include major
alterations to the existing roof
structure of the application property
but no bat report
worth noting is that beech ash and oak
trees are particularly suitable for bats
surely a scoping bat survey or
preliminary roost assessment is needed
before any decision can approve the
destruction of this tree on the back of
this huge extension
moving to another direction the proposal
for a large roof terrace to the rear of
the property which clearly overlooks
number nine
is mitigated by an opaque screen 1.8
meters in height by 4.8 meters of depth
a glass and steel structure of
significant dimensions
8.6 square meters
or 92 square feet
really
that size
that mitigation
itself creates an incongruous eyesore
surely clashing grossly with the proper
vista of brickwork and roof tiling
it will create an impaired vista
unfairly imposed on a neighbor
so committee this application is a step
too far
too far forward that is
too far towards a protected tree
too far towards another home someone's
home their bedroom windows
there is scope on the site
size
sorry there is scope on a site of this
magnitude to accommodate the planned
features the applicant seeks
in a much less damaging and intrusive
way
on that basis and with careful
consideration
i'm asking the committee to refuse this
application
and suggest that the applicant goes back
to the large site to think again more
considerately
thank you thank you ken silwetten
um mr healey do you want to um
sit in the in the place where cancel the
wetton was
[Music]
anybody yeah if you press the the button
so the microphone lights up and just
bring the microphone close to you so we
can pick up what you're saying or sit
closer yeah that's great
good evening everyone i'm bernard healey
and with my family i've happily lived at
22 bumble chase for 28 years
our home sits on a triangular plot
leaving us vulnerable to overlooking
especially if spd4 principles on
distances were to be breached
travel council states 21 metres is
required to enable compliance with spd4
and l7 principles the distance between
our daughters south facing bedroom
window and the proposed
north elevation windows are 10 meters
and 30 meters approximately
still very close
a previous planning application was
refused on the grounds of overlooking
distance and mass
the development was smaller extension of
100 of 81 meters squared
versus the current proposed larger more
dominant extension of
184 meters squared in mass
the development is also 8.5 meters
closer to our windows than the previous
the council have attempted to mitigate
the reduced distance by nearly half the
requirement with obscured
glazed windows on the
western most north facing front bedroom
window which is only one of the two
windows this is a poor design and is
employed by other front facing windows
being clear and transparent i believe
this not a solution but adds to the fact
that the design will be aesthetically
out of place and not in keeping with
local immunity
the second key issue is the committee
relies on an inaccurate
report
provided by the applicant demon the oak
tree tea want to be a tree in poor
health this is in fact untrue and a much
more accurate detailed and credible
report characterized mature oak tree as
an a2 high quality tree
a particular visual importance with a
minimum life expectancy of at least 40
years
this tree is also protected by
a tpo the tree has an actual rpa of 930
not 650 as per tree solutions
report
the ubf tree report shows the tree scale
of the tree including the rpa with
photographic evidence and shows the
proposed north elevation of the
extension coming into contact with the
rpa root protection area
the applicant initially informed
plumbing officers that there were no
trees or hedges on the property within
falling distance of the pros proposed
development or any trees or hedges that
would need to be removed
and did not submit a tree report till
over 12 months after his initial
application
finally the proposed divine deserve
development is not in keeping with any
of the existing properties on the road
in particular the choice of full height
windows including sandstone sills
soffits with an approximate height at
two meters
this includes the addition of proposed
roof terrace with a 1.8 meter screen
which is incongruous to the design and
will be a significant visual amenity
issue to those at number nine and an
invasion of their privacy
urban imprint who are charter town
planners working with trafford and many
other projects have criticized this
scheme has been non-compliant
uh their correspondences within the
bundle thank you thank you
thank you very much if you'd like to uh
return to your seat uh and we have a
speaker in support of the application
uh mr groves you're with us thank you mr
groves sheriff i may say at the start
there's so many inaccuracies in what
you've just been told could i have a
little bit longer given they've had
eight minutes to uh raise points which i
think are inaccurate no i don't think i
can allow you for the time because then
i don't well the committee will be
misinformed if they rely on the
information they've just been given well
we have the we've had the reports and
we've read them when we have the
officer's comments
there's new information just come out
there that's never been mentioned before
well i i can't vary time sort of
speakers because i would then have to
allow further time for the people have
already spoken so
you have three minutes mr groves and
we'll start the clock once you start
speaking thank you thank you chair i'm
john groves a chartered town planner
representing the applicant
this application was submitted in march
2021
since then your officers have exercised
their powers diligently in suggesting
amendments to improve the proposal in
each and every case my client has agreed
those amendments and accepts that as a
result the scheme is better as a
consequence of the planning process
the case officer report which has
clearly been carefully considered
and i stress rate covers all of the
issues raised in objection
you have 12 pages of analysis before you
which consider all issues raised in the
application of national and local policy
design and appearance immunity including
specific assessment of impact on
properties either side trees and parking
the report concludes that paragraph 34
the proposal is acceptable and has no
unacceptable impact
unfortunately one neighbor continues to
have issues and has deluged offices with
late information which in fact brings
nothing new to the table and which has
not been fully addressed in the office
report
the objector has had more than 12 months
to provide detailed appraisal of the
condition of a tree which planning
permission has already existed to enable
removal there is 2016 planning
permission consent to to remove the tree
over which so much fuss is being made
it is a dubious tactic to produce rafts
of material after the expiry of any
formal period of consultation
simply to confuse and muddy
consideration rather than produce any
information which assess members in
making decision
my clients have contacted the
arboriculturist who submitted the 2015
application for consent to fell and i
provided your officers with a statement
from him which states the details of
that consent and the treat which it
related
your late submissions report properly
shows office consideration of the
slightly desperate red herring issues
concerns over the impact of 22 are
comprehensively addressed in paragraphs
25 to 27 of the report and accept the
proposed conditions revised plans and
obscure glazing for windows the new
window is a the second window of that
bedroom and it's mirrored on the other
side of the building so it would be
symmetrical in the facade
there are many and agrees in
inaccuracies in the submissions made the
objective including misreading of plans
and a claim that there is a view from
skylights which sit nine feet above
floor level
copious submissions about trees chooses
to ignore the basic advice of your
council's forestry officer but again
critically admits to refer to the fact
that trees previously made the subject
of a consent to fell in 2015
we disagree and our forestry officer
contends that his uh our borrowed
cultural assessment is correct and
accurate there is nothing which has been
presented in objection which would
provide you with justification to go
against office recommendation a decision
based on emotive subjective and
irrational assertions would of course
run the risk of challenge on appeal i
would ask you to follow your office
recommendation thank you chad thank you
mr graves
um
before i open up to members of the
committee i wonder mr dave he could
just help us because a lot a lot of the
information that we've heard and was in
the
sort of late documents related to the t1
tree uh and there is a lot of
information in there
is is it possible for you to sort of
summarize what the key considerations
are for us as a committee around the
removal of that tree
um
yeah um
the application
proposes the removal of the tree as part
of the
application works
we we clearly have two uh
different arbor cultural assessments
that
have different views about the
the merits of the tree um
um
but the view of our
of the council's arbory culturist is um
that the tree um
um is is not of high immunity value
um and that it does have deep pruning
wounds um
and that
unbalanced crown and for that reason
she can't um
she wouldn't be able to object to the
removal of the tree
um
that's not dependent on the um
the previous uh tree works application
2015 which
unfortunately
the council's records are not very clear
about
what specifically was permitted in
relation to that tree
in terms of that application but it but
the view of the arborist culturalist is
not dependent on that
um so her advice is um that she can't
she doesn't feel that she would be able
to object to the removal of the tree
notwithstanding that um
our view within the
um
as expressed within the additional
information report is um
that the
extension would be acceptable
whether the tree is removed or not and
obviously it could be
it could be decided that the tree should
be retained in which case there could be
um
potentially conditions um to try to
retain
the tree um which might involve
foundation design um
in terms of the extension
um
but we
as officers we don't consider that the
the acceptability of the extension is
dependent on
the tree remaining or
or screening on that boundary
we consider that because of the angle
between the windows
um
there would not be an unacceptable loss
of privacy in any case
um
that's really helpful thank you mr day
um
okay any members of the committee
looking
uh yeah councillor morgan has a question
thank you thank you chair um it's just a
it's just a question for officers that
hopefully will help other other members
and just based on what stage you said
i've got a second question so i've just
quit and what you were saying is the
records aren't great but just looking at
the
application from 2015 it says relating
to i think this tree which we're
referring to which is an oak tree it
says removal of several different trees
but it says minor weight reduction of
the longer limbs of one oak tree which i
deem quite minor work not removal and
then my second question is is this
permission to take the tree out or is
this the tree could be taken out without
this
is this proposal the extension plus the
tree removal is that is it just the
extension we're approving tonight
sorry i've just bombarded you with a lot
of words
yeah i mean i mean the application has
submitted at the moment does include
plans that show the removal of
of the tree that's within the um
cultural assessment
um so as it stands it would
i think that the permission would um
if granted as it stands would it would
allow the removal of the tree yeah
perhaps it's worth perhaps it's worth
clarifying chair if i may this might
help that you can apply to remove a
protected tree either separately through
tree preservation
legislation or as part of the planning
application so either way is is
acceptable and would grant the felony
um yeah thank you to you both for that
information so i think i think we work
on the basis that the tree will be
removed if the application is
is approved at cancer diagnosis
sorry just following on from what ms
coley said so it's within our remit here
to include the tree in our decision
making is that what you're saying
right
whilst i have a microphone can i just
ask um it was mentioned that some of the
bedroom windows are proposed that they
are glazed with obscured glass
and that
um from what i can see in the report
they are to be fixed closed
is is that the case is that um usual is
that
have we had other examples before us
where bedroom windows have been
um
fashioned in such a such a way
um
if where you've got um a single
principal bedroom window uh window to a
bedroom then we wouldn't normally um
um allow that to be or
we wouldn't normally put a condition on
requiring that to be obscure glazed and
and so it's fixed up to 1.7 meters per
floor level it's not it's not proposed
to be fixed shut completely
but the difference in this case is that
there were two
bedroom windows there are two windows
serving that room so there would still
be a clear outlook
from the room from the other window
and that's that's the reason why
we consider that to be
an acceptable solution in this case if
it was the only window into the bedroom
then no we wouldn't consider that to be
acceptable and and
so you consider the glazed option the
obscured glazing preferable to no
windows at all would that make the room
unacceptable if it only had the one
window that you that is okay to leave
usually glazed
that one one window on its own would be
inadequate is that what you're saying
so the the room the success of the room
depends on it having three windows two
of which because of the proximity of
neighbor require obscure glazing
well so it's got two windows um one of
which would be
obscure glaze
um
i mean i mean that's obviously that's
that's
the question of removing the window is
not
not a scenario that's been put to us at
the moment i mean
until now so i mean
obviously the additional window would
provide additional light into the room
but um
i mean i suppose in terms of
our our consideration in terms of
amenity um
i don't think it would be i don't think
we would say that it has an unacceptable
level of amenity if there was only the
one window serving the room now
right okay so we're keeping two windows
one with obscure glazing to allow extra
light into the room is that right yeah
yeah that's that's the recommendation at
the moment yeah
okay thank you
um
yeah i think it probably would so yeah
we'll just show the layout so you can
see members can see that
[Music]
i'll show you
sorry
is that all right
sorry
so yeah there you can see um
the room on the proposed plan on the
right hand side
um
at the bottom left hand corner
which one is it that's all right it's
the bottom it's the bottom one yeah and
the one that's closest to the corner
would
is recommended to be
so i have a plan
from
the applicant's tree report um
that just shows the layout the site
layout
and shows the angle between
the windows in number 22 and um
the clear glazed window in in the
application property setup
obviously that doesn't show the internal
layout
i'm really sorry so there are two
windows um within that um dotted circle
am i guessing is that the angle we're
looking at
well
yeah i mean i appreciate this drawing
also shows
i appreciate that line is drawn
back
yeah it's further back because
because the the two-story extension is
set back for the meter from the um
[Music]
from the ground floor elevation
so just to clarify um
the top edge of that hatch box that
jumps into this dotted circle
is set further back which would seem to
me to perhaps give more of a view than
it's it's one meter further back from
would that not increase the vision yeah
it would slightly um
yeah i mean the angle is slightly less
acute yeah yeah so the window on the
left of that hatch block is glazed and
the window towards the middle of the
property is
clear
yeah yeah okay yeah thank you
it does it
it draws my attention because it is an
unusual situation i don't think it's one
that i've come across and it does
beg the question of of whether it is
um to imposing them on number 22 but
perhaps other colleagues would have a
view on that
thank you
thank you
any other members looking to speak
councillor thomas thank you thank you um
quick question what's the discipline
difference between that wall and um
number 22
so
the distance to the corner of the
extension will be about ten and a half
meters um but the distance to
the
clear glazed window would be about 14
meters thank you
okay just carrying on
once i appreciate it's a very drastic
change to
what what is there already there are
in the street scenes similar houses with
similar frontages maybe not as extended
and
i don't have a particular problem with
either the design
the distances that we're talking about
um in terms of
that particular window
and
potential screens between
the two houses again i think that can be
quite easily worked out
to have a balcony with a 1.8 meter
screen across it
by choice
to protect the neighbor's privacy and
the subsequent um
rail at the end of the the roof terrace
being set back 75 centimeters
also increases the the privacy of number
nine i think it is
in
generally the the the actual situation
in situ in the houses
is at number nine which is probably
slightly more affected
um
with this development is slightly angled
it's angled away so it falls it sort of
falls back so if you to look at 90
degrees from the wall
you won't get into you won't see the
back of the property of number nine is
he's quite
fortunate in the way that it falls away
i think the science is big enough to
cope with it i can't see any issues in
matting
um we always have the same objections
about juliet balconies but
there are in-situ windows there
and
the tree report
i'm quite content to go with trafford's
alba called arboriculturist
who has classified the tree as c3
so in in light of that i'm quite happy
to propose that we accept the
recommendations of the officer in this
case
thank you council thomas air council
menace
that picture that you just showed the
one that's obviously not quite right
because it's obviously set back a bit
further actually really shows that even
with
especially with it being set back a
little bit further how much the tree
there actually screens so much
um between them and i think that's where
the tree isn't where you've got the
in yeah so with the removal of the tree
to me actually it makes it even
if you imagine how it is now with the
tree there and the house obviously not
extended is quite different quite
starkly different to
the house being extended and the loss of
the tree i think
the tree staying there would actually
make it not as bad
for the neighbours um i feel like the
tree mitigates a hell of a lot of the
you know
the sort of the closeness and like
that kind of feeling i think it i feel
it mitigates it um i don't know how i
mean obviously i don't know how having
an extension with the tree in place
would affect the tree and whether the
tree is going to survive so much going
on in the ground
um so close to the tree um so that's
another question i have about that part
[Music]
is it an option to have the extension
with with keeping the tree and would the
tree be adversely affected as in would
it then
you know
become sick and die potentially because
i don't want the tree it's an old tree
clearly an old oak tree can i don't
really want that to happen
i mean i mean we can't we can't know for
sure whether the tree would
survive i i did i did ask that question
specifically of the albury cultural
officer and
she felt that um
there could be
there could be conditions that um
could be applied to seek to retain the
tree it would probably involve special
foundation
design in relation to the extension um i
mean i suppose one of the
one of the points that she's made is
that
she feels obviously that that part of
the
root protection area is already under
tarmac anyway so
it it may not be as much of an impact as
as might be might otherwise be the case
but so she felt that it might
it might be possible to put conditions
on um but it would be possible to put
conditions on what we can't guarantee is
that that would
you know or for how long that would
ensure
the tree survives but um
it would be possible
to seek the retention of the tree and
put conditions on
okay thank you um
sorry counselor
thank you
can i just ask it seems to me that if we
were to reject your proposal would there
be a strong case
for the applicant to appeal and the
likelihood of them winning that appeal
based on
you were
agreeing with the plans in the first
place
does that have any impact because i'm
worried about being caught up in
unnecessary legal fees when
the officers have done their role and
we're arguing about a tree and um being
overlooked by 10.5 metres away which is
a good my in old money 30 feet isn't it
well
yeah i think the window would be about
the clear glazed window would be about
14
meters away
obviously at an angle
our viewers officers was
that that
you know i suppose i suppose
in any in any proposal which is not
completely clear-cut we're obviously
weighing up whether we would
if we were to refuse an application on
that basis whether we would
be likely to win an appeal on that basis
and
i suppose our view was yeah that we
wouldn't be likely to win an appeal on
that but um
i i fully accept that
because the issue is about a window
at an angle we don't have a specific
guideline for
for each specific angle
um that there is a matter of judgment
there so um
can i just ask when it says 21 meters is
that when the window is directly
opposite
because somebody mentioned 21 meters and
yeah so so when it's at an angle there's
some
play basically that's what you're saying
well
the 21 meter guideline um
[Music]
is obviously a guideline that
that is
that has been drawn up um on on the
basis of a standard relationship where
you've got
windows directly opposite each other and
perhaps across the highway
um
so the more you depart from that
standard relationship the more
i suppose the more
the potential that you would need to to
relax that
okay in that case i'm happy to second
the proposal
thank you uh
councillor bunting
yeah
thank you chairman um we're acting
german sorry um
i'm going to disagree with council
thomas and cancer you know i'm happy to
i'll be proposing
the opposite direction i'll be proposing
uh that we go against officer
recommendation and refuse in terms of
the tree first
as has been commented on previously that
the agriculture says essentially too
much damage done to the tree to
concern
to
hold up the protection now well that's
only because previously the
former culturalists
instructions were disregarded as he's
stated quite clearly in in the report
you know that the
there was permission given for mario so
a minor trim and it was then given the
mother and father of all haircuts
you know what it says here the former
the former tree officer derek austin
commented the tree receiving very harsh
pruning which was not what he granted
permission for
you know that's fairly
that's a fairly clear statement
um and derek austin is the man that i
would trust i knew him i worked with him
for a number of years
with him for a number of years and i i
trust his judgment on that
um i know the other
articles may disagree but i'm gonna uh
yeah i think their costume was a
an extremely credible source
so
in terms of the
the tree i'm not satisfied to
remove the protection of the tree
regardless of whether it goes ahead or
not i would want to see that protection
remain in place and as a minimum even if
we were to accept this uh
officer recommendation which i i don't
but if we were to i would want to see
that tree remain in place and if plants
had to be amended slightly in terms of
foundations and what have you to ensure
that that tree remained um
viable
i believe that should be it should be
done in terms of the actual application
itself in terms of the building i'm
i'm not as concerned about the rear as i
am as concerned about the front i think
the impact on 22 is is unacceptable this
is coming very much uh far further
forward the two windows uh
in order to resolve the problem
regarding the windows i disagree with
the officers and thought you'd only be
able to obscure one of them the only way
you could make it acceptable in terms of
22 would make it unacceptable in terms
of this site i obscure both of them but
then again as officers have already
pointed out it wouldn't be acceptable to
insist on both windows within the
bedroom to be upscale glazed therefore
you can't avoid the impact on 22
therefore the condition fails to resolve
the problem
so
if we were to i'd i think it would have
a a significant overlooking impact on 22
and as has been pointed out i think it
was counselor dagnan pointed out that by
pulling the front
back by the meter you actually make the
problem worse because you change the
angles on it you make it overlooking
more of an impact uh yes the overlooking
would be
mitigated to a degree only to a degree
by the presence of the tree but then
again if the applicant gets it as per
the report then the tree will be removed
anyway
so i think that i also feel
that the size scale and massing as per
the previous application which is what i
said was a smaller application is uh is
is also a significant issue in terms of
this application and therefore the
so i would agree with the preview with
the previous refusal which to get
accounts like i know this point yes we
did win the previous yeah previously
it was refused and that was upheld
um
so
i i can't see that this application is
acceptable principally for me
because of that corner going on to 22.
if it was if it was if it was just a
real extent being done in the way that's
been proposed i wouldn't have so much of
an issue with it for whilst i accept
that nine may not be happy i think
there's a fair degree of screening there
already with the existing and the uh
addition additions that we made to the
rear would make that
acceptable and reasonable but not not
great but acceptable but for me it's
that corner bordering onto 22 that makes
it unacceptable and so for those reasons
chairman uh i can't i can't accept the
officer's recommendation and i post
refusal on those two grounds one the uh
immunity impact on 22 in terms of the
overlooking made worse by the fact that
the tree is to be removed and two the
increase in the mass of the building
having the detrimental impact
upon the street scene uh thank you
chairman
uh thank you councillor bunting
so i think the position with the tree
the previous uh permission to prune the
tree is we don't have records from that
so we so we don't know i don't think
what permission was actually given um
and i don't think we can speculate i
think we've got to take the tree as it
is for now and and whether
whether we are happy for that tree to be
removed given given its current current
state so chairman if i may just to
clarify my position i am satisfied that
the tree itself to me
uh does look viable i still think it
still has a valuable contribution and so
even in the condition in which it is
presently i still support the retention
of the protection order upon that tree
gem thank you okay i'm sort of councilor
bunting uh councillor wins stanley
ah thank you chair i've listened to the
debate with great interest tonight and i
read the reports of great interest and i
was really fascinated by the input from
the people who spoke on uh both for and
against this is not an easy one it's an
it's an odd-shaped site
it's a large extension but i think
overall
um even given the extensive arguments
about the tree i'm not happy about the
fact that we have to obscure one of the
windows to protect the privacy of the
the house next door
that doesn't sit well with me
um and there is lots of issues around
the
distances
but overall i think i'm going to vote in
support of this
a big thing which swings me in support
of this is the applicant has worked um
extensively with our
planning team and has followed the
advice of our planning team at every
stage
um and that is refreshing to find a
developer who is willing to do that and
i think we will be perverse to turn this
down
after the work they put in so i will be
voting uh in favor of the officer
recommendation thank you chair
thank you council uh councillor morgan
please thank you
thank you chair um
i i i i think i've got less problems
with this application than probably a
lot of other speakers um um
i'm not going to go over the same
arguments but to want to see that i'm
listening to cancer thomas probably
he um articulated what a lot of my
thinking was was on this um
but i i i i think i probably agree with
council reminiscent council bunting that
i i really do think
we
if we can try and keep this tree when
reading the reports it doesn't seem any
reason we can't
just looking at some of the the the
graphs and the geography of this tree in
some ways it's closer to
um or it could its roots could
potentially be close to 22 than 24. um
so i i really would support and
um guidance if there's anything we can
do in terms of putting a condition into
to try to keep this tree and i think
that would improve a lot of the problems
that have been articulated about
um the having to glaze one of the
windows and obscuring i think a lot of
those would be
um
reduced significantly if we did keep
we're able to keep this tree um but
regardless i will be supporting the um
application tonight thank you
thank you catch the morgan uh council
thomas you want to come back here thank
you i just uh just did a little bit of
clarity if i could uh as as you've just
mentioned there's no record of the scope
of the tree pruning so i don't think we
can hold that into
um
banes on on how we decide going forward
but just for clarity
if the tree is great as c3 which has
been by trafford's arboriculturist
um
if we put a condition in place on this
proposal to retain the tree
can the applicant therefore then go to
gpa and apply for it to be
removed
under a separate way just just for
clarity so everyone knows i'm quite
happy with my decision i'm just gonna
so everyone's quite sure
of where we stand with the tree
um i'll have to do some googling to find
the answer out to that
okay good because if you've gone for a
tpa
it would seem convenient
he would be able to remove it that's all
i just want to
get the clarity around the tree it's a
shame if an old tree gets taken down yes
i agree but
in the whole scheme of the whole plan
that is an option that we have to take
into consideration that if he went on
for a tpa first he would probably have
been removed without any objection thank
you
thank you i suppose yeah i think that's
a good question we'll try and find
answers to that uh any other members
looking to speak councillor welton
[Music]
thanks chair
um i
find myself in agreement with those who
are saying that this might be more
acceptable if the tree was
kept in place i do understand that the
um you know what people have been saying
that the
the um
plans have been changed substantially in
uh
working with planning officers but i
feel that that has only been had to
happen because mitigation was required
because an unacceptable design was put
in front of us in the first
was put in front of them in the first
place so i think there's you know
there's limited congratulations that
needs to be
needs to be given there and you know the
fact that several windows are having to
be screened and so and big screens are
being put up is possibly you know
suggests that the design should have
been different in the first place i
think everybody would be much more
comfortable if the tree was in place um
and
if it can be retained then fantastic
then i will vote to um
to accept the scheme if not i will be
happy to
second councillor bunting's proposal to
reject this thank you very much
thank you i think we have an answer
around the um the
tpr
the condition would
trump the tpo application process that
would also require a variation of con
condition so you could
in theory grants consent to fallen under
a tpo but without the consent under the
condition then the tree couldn't be
removed however
the one it's a tree is a living um
thing so
what we cannot guarantee is the
retention of that tree forever it could
die next year we don't know so
if if members are
thinking should be retained they
shouldn't be relying entirely on it for
screening because it is it's a you know
it it will have a life span and the
extension um
will be there in perpetuity or until the
property has changed again
thank you
so a number of members have
raised the you know the tree is an issue
and wanting to retain uh retain the tree
um
so i think what we'll do is we'll
probably maybe vote on that first on
whether to uh if we were going to uh
grant planning permission whether we
want to include
conditions which would attempt to
preserve the tree or obviously we don't
know what will happen
well
i think i think certainly councillor
welton you you indicated that you would
like to see that change uh and i'm
i think another against the ministry you
also mentioned that didn't you so i
think we do have a proposal in a second
thank you counselor so um
so i think first of all we'll we'll vote
on that whether we
think that the conditions should include
and i'm guessing we'll just have to
allow some
discretion as to exactly what the
wording will be because we don't know
yeah okay so we'll we'll delegate
authority to uh to draft of appropriate
conditions has there been a second of
the motion to refuse
yeah yes well um which case we need to
take that next
next do we okay
yeah councillor walton i i understood to
be second in the the motion to refuse on
the basis of the application as it is
that's yeah okay so yeah okay we'll take
that one first then all right
yeah yeah okay
okay so we'll we'll we'll uh we'll vote
on um councillor bunting's motion that
we disagree with our officer
recommendation and that we
um
can people who are viewing the committee
please not make comments uh i find it
very distracting and you did ask very
pleasantly at the beginning that once
they've had
five or three minutes that they should
no longer be active it's a committee
meeting not a chair with a
comment from the floor thank you with
respect thank you with respect with
respect sir with respect sir if we need
you we'll ask you we you were asked by
the chair at the very beginning of the
meeting not to interrupt after you've
had three minutes i support this plan
but i'm very tested by the way you keep
interrupting and it's very difficult for
members
to uh continue with the discussion
around the plan so for you if you
wouldn't mind please thank you chair
thank you council thomas so um
so the the the uh the advice that we
were discussing was in what order to
take the motions and and to check we had
a proposed room secondary um for each so
i'll i'll i'll perhaps just just clarify
so we're going to take the motion to
refuse permission first proposed by
councillor bunting seconded by cancer
welton um
we will then
if we need to take the motion on whether
to amend the conditions to
uh include conditions aimed to set a
tree i understand council administer
you're happy to move that and councillor
diagonal you will have to second that
and then if necessary we'll go on to uh
consider the grants which uh
canceled thomas you prepare was then
encountered like another i think you
seconded okay so that's the order that
will
take the motion so the first the first
motion is
to
yeah sorry um we yeah i think councillor
bunting advanced some reasons didn't you
want us
and council bunting was clear about
those so it's the immunity issue to
number 22
and the increase in massing having a
detrimental impact on the streets we
just want members to be clear about what
they're voting on here thank you
um i was i didn't want to propose the
option with keeping the tree and
extending because i think the extending
is going to kill the tree ultimately and
i think the tree won't survive so i i
i'm just not a fan i think the extension
as it is on paper will kill the tree
rather we protect the tree for now
or not it's going to get killed so i'm
just not a fan
okay yeah i'm happy to propose it
if council diagnosed my own secondary
so we still have a positive second let's
vote on the uh on the motion to disagree
with officer recommendation
uh and refuse uh all those in favor of
that motion
we're voting now on the motion that
counselor bunting proposed to refuse
planning permission so all those in
favor of that motion to refuse if you
could raise your hands now
and all those against that motion
okay that motion uh is is defeated so
we'll we'll move on now to the second
motion whether to around the conditions
to include uh reference to measures to
try and protect the tree councillor
morgan proposed against the diagonal i
think you'll have to second
so uh all those
in favor of that motion if you could
raise your hands please
okay can you raise your hands please
thank you
[Music]
and those against please
four
okay so that motion is carried so
the uh
the proposal now is that we
approve planning permission but the
conditions will be uh
amended by the planning officers to
include those measures to protect the
tree
all right yeah okay
so that's the motion that's before us
now so all those in favor of that motion
of you
yes
yeah okay
so okay
all those in favour
so i thought the second one
sorry i'm just asking for clarification
sorry sorry members okay well let's just
let's just do that final vote again so
this this is to uh grant permission
with the conditions that we just
agreed to try to preserve the tree all
those in favor please
i know those against please
okay so
that motion that motion is
okay that motion is carried so uh
permission is granted um subject to the
conditions which will be amended by
officers to
include reference to protecting the tree
we're going to move on now to the
next item on the agenda
which is application number 105 482
of 21. that's five nozzle w in david
hume
we'll just pause for a moment while
people leave and enter
[Music]
thank you
okay for committee members benefit this
starts on page 14 of the bundle uh if we
could start next item please we're going
to have an introduction by mr day thank
you
thank you
start your introduction
so this application relates to a
two-story terrace drawing to the east
side of noseley avenue davian
permission is sought for the erection of
a single story rear extension
and a rear dormer
the application has been reported to
committee as an officer of the council
could be deemed to have an interest in
the application
less of objection have been received
from two neighbouring properties
these are on the grounds of increased
parking demand visual intrusion drainage
and design
the key considerations are the impact of
extensions on the visual immunity
of the area and on the residential
amenity of neighbours
the site benefits from an extent
planning permission which also committed
a rear dormer
whilst the design of the currently
proposed dormer does not comply with
spd4 guidance
the impact of the dormer would be no
worse than that approved in the extant
permission
and this fallback position represents a
material planning consist consideration
there outweighs any harm to visual
immunity as a result of the dormer
the single-story rear extension will
project 5.7 meters beyond the rear
elevation
of number seven noseley nosed avenue
with a separation distance of 900
millimeters to the shared boundary
this significantly exceeds the spd4
guidance of three meters
in addition to the gap to the boundary
it is considered that the extension will
be visually intrusive and have an
overbearing impact
on the occupiers of number seven
community policy l7 of the core strategy
is therefore recommended that permission
is refused
[Music]
uh thank you mr day um we
have a statement i think to be read in
favor of the application from uh mr
floyd miss cody's going to read that
thank you
thank you chairman um this is a
statement in support of the application
from from british floyd who is the
applicant's agent
thank you for allowing this statement to
support to be read we are aware that
there is a recommendation for refusal
however i would like to assure you that
the proposals have been produced with
complete respect for the neighbouring
properties and are much more considerate
to the neighbours and have a smaller
football print area than that allowed
through permitted development with this
in mind i would ask you to consider the
application on its own merits
as can be seen on the drawing the
proposal sits alongside the northern
property boundary extending three metres
from the rear elevation approximately
2.2 meters past the extension to number
three the eaves line is situated
adjacent to the boundary minimizing any
overshadowing to number three and is set
so that not no part not over in the
gutter will overhang the boundary line
in line with spd4 3.4.5 the proposal is
set off the southern boundary by 900
millimeters the proposal sits 2.5 metres
away from the outrigger wall of number
seven extending no further than the
existing extension number seven as with
the northern boundary we have run the
eaves line parallel with the southern
boundary to ensure the proposal is not
overbearing to number seven in any way
the proposal has been designed such as
to minimize the length of the boundary
facing wall returning this back into the
existing outrigger to allow light into
the existing window or door openings to
both number five and number seven
although due to the orientation there is
no possibility of any overshadowing to
number seven the combination of setting
the proposal away from the boundary away
from existing window openings and
running the eaves line at this location
minimizes any visual intrusion to number
seven
as such we believe this is compliant
with spd4 3.4.1
our proposed extension is similar in
footprint to that of number one
extending to the rear of the original
outrigger by increasing the width number
one has a larger footprint than our
proposals as it has infilled the
remaining alcove right at the party wall
line creating further internal space
this would have had a significant impact
on number three should they have not
also filled the alcove our proposal
retains an alcove and as such eliminates
this impact on number seven we know this
footprint isn't completely in accordance
with spd4 guidance which is why the
planning officer has recommended refusal
however we believe that following sp4
3.4.2 rigidly would in turn fall foul of
spd for 3.4 3.4.11
the issue relates to that the southeast
corner has a small 1.77 square meter
triangle of footprint sitting outside
the spd for 3.4.2 45 degree line it is
worth noting that a 0.66 square meter
triangle of a pd compliant development
would also sit outside of this line as
such we're asking for a slight
relaxation for a length of 1.8 meters
the south elevation and 0.7 meters the
east elevation to allow the proposal to
be squared off in order to comply with
spd4 3.4.11
we believe this falls within the spirit
spd4 3.4.8 in conjunction with the
precedent set by number one
as illustrated the use height will be no
more than three meters as such is not
only in full accordance with spd for
guidance but also compliant with the
permitted development rights for
householders please note the proposed
eaves height is also slightly lower than
the ease of existing extension number
three
there's another two paragraphs um which
in summary um
relate to the design of the extension
being submit submissive to the existing
building
and quotes the mppf in respect of high
quality design of places
and believes that the extension follows
that uh policy thank you chairman thank
you miss um
and before we start counseling i'm sorry
i didn't realize you'd left the room and
we we had started this item before you
returned so i think you'll have to sit
this one out okay uh any other members
looking to speak on this one councillor
win stanley
uh thank you chair um
this is this is an interesting one i
spent
uh
20 minutes at the rear of the house this
afternoon scratching my head as to why
we were turning it down
um because i
looked at the i looked at the format of
the proposal i can see it doesn't
according to the um
according to the report doesn't comply
with spd4 as the applicant says in the
thing in the letters of a letter of
support for this
may not with the letter of it it
definitely complies with the spirit of
it doesn't it doesn't it will not um
i think impact on the houses on either
side
and more importantly for the um for the
general layout of the rear of the houses
it will be very much in keeping with the
extensions which are which were on the
houses on either side
so i think i will be voting to go
against officer recommendation and to
to approve the application thanks chair
thank you uh cancer canal
mine was similar as in looking at the
outlines and looking at number one and
number
seven and number fifteen all seemed to
have to go out as far as their
extensions and i couldn't understand
why that was an issue um
i couldn't understand it a bit more if
it was about a dorm or um
but um i'm struggling to understand why
this is being rejected when there's
already other things that are already in
place that seem to set a precedent
so i'd um i'm also in mind to um second
barra and um go against officer
recommendations on this one
thank you uh councillor bunting
thank you chairman at the risk of
sounding like an echo um i'm gonna
broadly agree uh
with two previous two speakers
the only disagreement i would have is
i'm not
obviously basing anything i appreciate
there were no precedents in planning and
so the fact that others have done it is
not the the issue for me it's simply
viewing this site entirely in its own
merits i genuinely can't see
can't see the problem um i'm you know i
agree with counseling stanley i stood at
the back of this
property looked at it and thought
why am i here
um
you know it's it's one of those ones
sometimes you can see both sides of the
arguments and something you can play
either way and say well i could make a
speech at planning committee supporting
either side
this one i'm genuinely lost uh by the by
by by the concerns i i i don't see any
significant issue in relation to this if
anything it will improve
the look of the back of the building and
improve uh the general surroundings so
i'm more than happy to uh support the
previous two speakers if i can take that
as proposal and seconder i'm more than
happy to vote along that way and go for
uh against officer accommodations grant
thank you chairman
thank you uh council from maitland yep
thank you
thanks chair um i agree totally with
the three of you i could not see any
reason for this to be in fact i think
it's a beautiful looking extension
from the plans but i couldn't understand
why it was being refused
uh councillor choking thank you
just to add to the chorus um the uh i
just as i i i i
agree
most with with what the others have all
said i can't
see why we would refuse us however the
site probably doesn't benefit well it's
very tight
so i can understand why there'd be some
hesitation and some concern that number
seven would be overshadowed but um
or have a lot to either but i don't see
why
i can actually support refusal on this
one
okay thank you guys for thomas
yeah just briefly my house is exactly
the same shape as this one and if my
neighbors approached me with a
reasonable extension to do that i've
seen no problem the wall the outrigger
wall is huge anyway i step out and all i
can see is a wall
so i can't see any reason to refuse
thank you
okay thank you it's been moving second
we disagree with officer's
recommendation ellie
uh any members take a different view
anyone else wanting to contribute um
so the it's been moving seconded that we
uh
disagree with the officer recommendation
and that we if we grant planning
permission um that would be subject to
uh if you like standard conditions and
we'll delegate the drafting of those
conditions to officers um so if members
are happy to to do that then we'll
then we'll vote on that motion to grant
yeah okay
uh council when stanley you wanted to
wait for it wait for it okay
sorry so uh yeah all those in in favor
of the motion to grant permission
okay
so i think
that is unanimous apart from councillor
should be
12 i think
yeah
okay that application uh is uh
granted uh we'll move on to the uh
next application on the list number 105
708 which is
uh inglewood house
and that starts at page 23 of your
bundles and we'll start with an
introduction from miss coley thank you
just bear with me uh counselors that for
some reason the slideshow is on my
screen but not up there and i don't know
why
is uh mr massey with us yeah okay yeah
okay i'll come to you know whatever
thank you
have i got time for a quick comfort
break so i don't miss the voting while
you're fiddling
uh yeah
yeah um
you
thank you for your patience there um
thank you
this
uh application seeks a change of use of
part of the premises at uh inglewood
house in hall lane in partington to form
a day nursery part of the building
formerly inglewood cottage would be
maintained in residential use the
application site is located on the
corner of hall lane in inglewood close
which you can see on the screen there in
partington the surrounding area is
predominantly residential in nature
the nursery would include four
classrooms across two floors with
storage allocated on the second floor
the existing driveway would be extended
to allow for five
staff drop off and parking spaces
including two wider spaces a small rear
extension is proposed to accommodate
toilet facilities
total of 15 letters of objection and
nine letters of support are being
received in relation to this application
the main objections are in relation to
inadequate parking provision increased
traffic highway safety and noise and
disturbance
the applicant supported the application
with a noise assessment noise management
plan
complaint policy and complaint record
template daily routine and class
timetable including an equal opportunity
policy
special education needs and disability
policy and noise and traffic statement
following a receipt of additional
information the pollution licensing team
the local highway authority have
released no objection to the proposals
subject to the number of conditions
officers are satisfied that
appropriately worded conditions
including restricting the number of
overall children restricting the number
of children outside at any one time
hours of use installation of acoustic
fencing restricting the future occupies
the retained dwelling to owners or staff
members and operating in accordance with
an agreed noise management plan would
satisfactorily mitigate any potential
adverse noise impacts from the proposed
use
no harm would arise to
highway safety or any other
consideration again subject to
to suitable controlling conditions the
equality's impacts of the development
has been considered and are in a
balanced judgment considered to be an
appropriate practical and reasonable
response in terms of the accessibility
of the development to those with a
disability the facility itself would be
a benefit to those with protect
pregnancy and motility as a protected
characteristic
as such the proposed development will
comply with the development plan and is
therefore recommended that permission be
granted subject to conditions there are
minor updates to these conditions in the
additional information to reflect the
most dope to date plan submitted i'd
also draw members attention to the uh
update to the equality section to
provide some clarification and it now
says what we what we it should have said
in the first place um rather than what
we thought it said thank you
thank you miss coley uh mr massey if
you'd uh
like to come forward and just have a
seat um
so speaking in favor of the application
so um you'll have um three minutes to
address it just make sure you're close
to the microphone so we'll pick out what
you say and um we'll start the timer
once you start talking thank you
thank you jack
good evening chair and members of the
committee what is the most valuable
thing we can pass on to our children
it's worth noting that all those
attending today including myself are
previous parents of mrs roberts class
and everyone was willing to deliver this
speech to champion anne and her setting
mrs robert's class has been rated
outstanding since the day she opened the
doors and we can see why the
effectiveness of her approach her
professionalism her ethos the love and
attention and care she puts into each
and every child and family cannot be
understated
we've heard the objections and we
understand
the one of the objections in relation
is in relation to noise
whilst
i like the sound of children playing
it's understand
i understand it's annoying to be
disturbed while trying to concentrate
thankfully most people are either out at
work or at lunch when the children are
active for the few who have have to deal
with it the acoustic report has shown
that the sound of children playing
outside their loudest to be 50 decibels
or the same as a concept conversation
for anybody outside the setting 10 times
less than traffic and 32 times less than
what we perceive industrial noise to be
like the construction currently
happening in the area
the noise generated from a nursery
nursery is negligible and well within
torrible boundaries nevertheless surface
and boundary treatments have been
carefully chosen to mitigate noise
transfer
the uh the other objection is traffic i
understand traffic is frustrating
especially rush hour or when trying to
park but there are 400 new houses being
built
behind the developer behind the
inglewood house and traffic is coming
regardless
mrs robert's class is small
bringing little traffic and has little
and it has a flexible attendance
structure spreading the drop off and
pick up times throughout the day again
our impact here is negligible
lastly there is i think an unspoken
favorite expansionism i understand
worries that some faces corporation
coming and and displacing people ruining
livelihoods this isn't the case here the
montessori nursery isn't big it's small
just 30 children two groups of 12
children and a baby baby room for six
the nursery isn't expanding it's
relocating from broadhead where anne had
lived for 30 years and is having to
relocate for personal reasons
broadhead is only two bus stops away and
is a local business woman who takes
takes local children hires locally and
trains locally
the last student she trained with south
traffic college was from was from
partington and before that brought heath
northerned in sale and wants to bring
her important services to partington
in 2018 the education secretary pledged
to invest 50 million across the early
years with further studies commissioned
and calls to improve to improve the
state of early education occurring in in
the commons as recently as january this
year it's an important issue
each iteration of the ey fs grows closer
to tuan's close-knit highly
communicative montessori style
with a growing focus on positive
environments small class sizes
communication with parents
child lead exploration and well-being
social engagement and the outdoors
inglewood is an ideal setting to
implement this so back to the first
question what is the most valuable thing
we can pass on to our children education
as it's shown time and time again
education especially at the foundation
stage the stage where where everything
else will be built upon and investment
in education will pay the best interest
thank you
thank you mr massey um
any members looking to
council the minis
i really like the ideas idea and i'll be
i like the fact that yeah there's that
is enough parking quite frankly to drop
your child off
and then you're going um and you're
going to have people you know
i've had my my my little ones were at
nursery
um it wasn't and it's not an issue and
there's flexibility with picking up
times because people work different
hours um yes absolutely fan i'll be
proposing that we accept officer
recommendation and grant this
thank you
thank you councilman sir councillor
yeah i'm happy to second this proposal i
think it is a sustainable site
particularly with a very large housing
estate being built
um just up the road i think it'll be a
useful facility um and i know that
they're they're hoping that 90 of the
children are going to walk or cycle
um or be carried to the nursery rather
than be carried in a car
so uh um so and i very much you know
wish them well with that that laudable
aim um i note the objections on you know
regarding traffic and noise but i don't
think they're sufficient to be able to
reject this proposal thank you
thank you councilwoman stanley
uh thank you chair i also applaud the
um the extra provision for nursery
places particularly this particular
variety of um
absolutely this this approach to nursery
education but i do have some issues with
the specific the specific proposal i was
a bit puzzled by the the noise
assessment wasn't reflecting the actual
situation which is before the committee
which was a minor objection
uh of more concern i'm not convinced
that the there won't be a large
detrimental effect on local parking fire
parking spaces is not enough um and you
can encourage people walking and cycling
as much as you want but people are
dropping the kids off the nursery
because they're going to school they're
probably going to drive
[Music]
i'm also unsure about the lack of
provision for accessible parking spaces
though i applaud the pragmatic approach
taken to this in the um in the report we
had a very bruising meeting here about
six months ago on if we cannot comply
with the letter of the law are there any
compromises we can make in terms of
accessible parking and that's kind of
been aimed at here we can't get the d
we can't get the length of the parking
space right to comply the left of the
law but we can get the width rise and i
applaud that approach being taken there
um my biggest my biggest concern this is
around accessibility and thank you to
the officers for dealing with my many
emails on the subject with great
patients over the course of the of the
last two days but i don't think again
that we use the equalities act to its to
its full extent large sections of this
will be inaccessible to any but any
parents or children
unless they are
able-bodied
um there's a great reliance on building
regulations to deal with this in the
report but building regulations will not
deal with this for two reasons first of
all they're not um they're not extensive
enough to deal with this and secondly i
know from my own town center there's a
problem with enforcement of building
regulation compliance within trafford
there are two premises in my local town
centre which are inaccessible and have
been reported many times to building
rags nothing has been done about it so
we cannot rely
uh in a planning meeting on building
regulations to uh to sort this out
uh
in the additional the additional
information report where you do talk in
more detail as you say it's a setting
there what probably should have been
said in the report but wasn't said we
talked about there the lack of property
the the problem of um putting a lift in
a 19th century building i live in the
19th century house with two lips in it
and the reason why i know it's possible
to do that the reason why i knew it was
possible to do that is because i spoke
to the experts within the council who
told me how to do that there's a whole
department devoted to this based out of
set in the um
in sale one stop center i used to sit on
the adaptations panel you can put you
can make anywhere accessible you just
need the will to do it
um
what i'm coming down to i don't disagree
with the proposal i think
the kind of recommendation i'll be
looking for today because i think if the
planning officers sat together with the
applicant you'd be able to work out a
way a very small expense to make at
least the first floor accessible
the top the top floor is storage space
even
i i suspect that might be a step too far
so i think if i'm
following through on my own head i think
what i'm proposing here
is that
we ask
the officers and the applicant
if we defer this to the next planner
meeting and then the officers work with
the applicants to come up with a
solution to solve the accessibility
problem so that at least the first floor
can become accessible to those who are
not uh completely able-bodied okay thank
you chair
uh thank you uh councillor morgan
thank you chair um and i think it's
gonna be a hard one to follow to
initially because actually i think
councilwoman stanley has brought some
really good points that i hadn't really
necessarily thought about um
i was more positive to be honest with
you but i'm kind of i'm really really
throwing my my my thoughts really um
and i was probably going to be voting in
favor of it before that but
i i mean the reservation i had was over
parking because it's not just about the
number of parking spaces it's the
structure of them um so
in effect two two of the parking spaces
are inaccessible once they're used um
and
i actually do think there is a
distribution because nursery is not at
school you don't drop somebody off and
pick them up at specific times there is
a distribution you know
some people probably like ourselves are
a half seven and six o'clock but um some
parents are a little bit more reasonable
with their kids um but um
similarly
you are you do have that stresses in
terms of in terms of time um and it just
concerns me um
that effectively we're saying we've got
three spaces really and how many and i
do know that they've said that
a lot of the a lot of the a lot of the
staff will will
won't drive but if they then do if we
have a change of staff um that's that's
a risk um
honestly i think i probably want to
listen to what other members think
because partly it's particularly what
councilwoman stanley said about the
accessibility um issues i think is very
very valid um
and i think we really do need to
consider that but um
probably um
uh observe any of the comments um later
and for the members thank you
thank you uh council hassan
i don't think sunny
issue i will fully support the office's
recommendation and i fully support my
counselor my colleague consummates and
council veterans there is no issue at
all and it should be granted
thank you okay
thank you um councillor thomas
thank you chair um again on the on the
accessibility i fully agree with council
win stanley um
yes should we have
opportunities for children to visit
and
improve their education preschool or
whatever yes we should
should we exclude anyone from
that opportunity
no we shouldn't it's discriminatory it's
not just
against a disability act it is
discriminatory there are as counseling
suddenly says
many ways that you can now install
uh equipment to facilitate access to all
floors of a building irrespective of the
age
it's just having the will to do it um 32
children
if you have
16 children that have
issues with disabilities and
acceptability going upstairs
after 16 do just ignore them and say
that they can't come my other thing that
and this is probably something that i've
i
could possibly vote against on
as has been mentioned there are 400
houses being built in the location in a
very close proximity to
this site
not only that
there's going to be a lot of building
traffic going through there the roads
are not designed in any way shape or
form
for heavy goods vehicles and certainly
not to have potentially an extra 800
cars being put in the location by the
development of the 400 houses
that that being said you have a school
of a montessori school on
a corner
of
a suburban lane it's not a road in any
way perform and with all due respect and
the attempts to have accessible parking
and create five spaces
in reality
the two that the staff use will be used
the the others generally won't take me
to hall lane on the edge where people
get out we see this every day at every
school in every ward in trafford and we
can't allow
people to
take risks with other people's children
or
themselves
by creating an issue and where this
where this is located on hall lane you
only got you've only got the site but
it's on a corner it's on a blind bend
and the the volume of tracking traffic
on there is going to increase two three
maybe four-fold from what it is at this
moment in time
so i i have grave reservations on on the
uh immunity through parking to people
and i'd like to see more done on the
accessibility
thank you chad but i'm not going to
propose
against at this moment yeah
thank you councillor diagno
um
i am sympathetic to this application um
i support the idea of
the montessori nursery i i respect that
their ideals and and it would be very
nice if those opportunities were offered
to children in parkington
however um
i'd like to reiterate what council win
stanley said i just don't think we can
tolerate any more any buildings any
public buildings at all
that have lack of access for people with
different abilities be their children
parents carers or staff
i just don't think we can go forward
agreeing with this anymore
um
probably
possibly not within our remit as an
ex-early years teacher i also really
really really struggle with the idea of
a nursery where access to the outdoors
is limited to the extent that it is
limited um my understanding of excellent
out early years learning is that
children have constant access to the
outdoors and for them to be limited in
this way to short half-hour sessions i
just think is unacceptable
um and that become that is obviously a
result of the nursery being located as
it is so close to
domestic dwellings
um i don't i personally wouldn't have an
issue with the noise i enjoy listening
to children play at local schools i can
just about hear them from my garden
but i would hate to think of those
30 40 children mentioned getting
half an hour's access to the outdoors in
the morning and another half hour in the
afternoon i just think that's dope not
okay
cancer
action yeah i think like others have
spoken i think
accessibility is is critical really
particularly for
a nursery
um
i
i don't sort of uh object to having a
nursery
uh in fact it's exact top of it but i
think the accessibility
is critical
um
and i think you know
it is a requirement of law in fact that
accessibility is built into these kind
of provisions um
and
um
what
has been suggested i think by councillor
when when stanley is
for this
i don't i don't want to see it disappear
completely but uh
you know if if we could defer it
um
so that there could be further
discussions to see how we can
get the accessibility right for this
um
for this development so
that's my view
um
i i think because yeah i know councilman
stanley proposed the deferral and i've
taken it from your comments casper
actually to support that so i think
um
i think i'll probably turn to miss carl
of some advice at that point thank you
thank you chair i think again this is
this is um
coming back to
your role as a planning committee um
which includes um as acknowledged in the
report um the
uh the equalities act in the public
sector equality duty um but ultimately
what
what uh how you should be making your
decisions is in accordance with the
development plan and we have no
development plan policy which requires
lift access to other floors we just we
we don't we don't have it
and the equalities act
also does not set that specific
requirement and we've had council advice
and the case law says this is a balanced
judgment
um
weighing up um all
all the impacts of of the scheme there's
no law
and there's
that
there must be
access to two upper floors the building
regulations
um
say that that there should be unless
unless it's designed out and that's an
opportunity and um
and
the
government advice on planning
and accessibility is that we
should um we shouldn't not be going
further than the building regulations
require the building regulations are
there to ensure accessibility they are
equalities you know that they have had
their own equality assessment and that's
how we should be um
how we should be dealing with it so
um i
i i don't
i don't and i'm not casting aspersions
on anything members have said i'm really
saying what the limitations are
for you as a planning committee
and
um
i don't think that it would be
considered reasonable and the applicant
could appeal against undetermination
for
this application to be deferred
for the insistence that a lift is um is
provided but obviously members are
entirely entitled to take a different
view but the risk is that they could
take that straight to appeal and that
decision will be taken out of your hands
entirely thank you
thank you
did you want to yeah i think
just in in response to
uh what's just been said i think case
law has established and it's in the
report that appropriate consideration of
equality issues is a requirement for
local authorities in the determination
of planning applications
and with this requirement directly
stemming from the equality act
2010 what we we're not saying is that we
oppose
this what we're saying is that we defer
this
um and i think that is reasonable and
that concurs with the act
that is you know heard before us as well
yeah
but but what i'm tr what i'm trying to
say is that yes you should consider it
but the equalities act does not set out
specific requirements for accessibility
in buildings that's what that's what i'm
saying so you can't say that the
equality act requires a lift in this
building because it doesn't that if you
if you defer the application on the
basis that
that's your interpretation of the law
that would not be a lawful decision well
i think what i'm saying is that a
deferral will allow some discussions
with the planning officers
and
the developer to
come to some
kind of different position we've got at
this moment in time that's all i'm
asking
if i can
and i'm not i'm not saying that members
should shouldn't do that i've just set
out the risk that they could then appeal
against an undetermination that that's
because we have no planning policy so
i'm just setting it in in the co as i
say i'm not casting aspersions on on the
the views of members and and you know
which are very valid
um
cancer and i can help we've
um i get really frustrated with this
because i work in the field of
disability and i know it's about
reasonability
um but if people are not asked the
question about whether they because it
really annoys me especially when there's
new buildings that come on board or a
change of use that that isn't the first
consideration about access for everyone
and in this particular building it's
quite a square-shaped building it'd be
not unreasonable for this to be a
through floor lift i've seen much more
complicated buildings that have managed
to accommodate either a free-flow lift
or
um chair lifts
um
i don't think it's unreasonable to defer
it to talk there to be some more
discussion about
access because it's
it's something new it's not an existing
build it's not an existing
service that we're
that's asking for a little change it's a
residential so resident a residence
that's being turned into another kind of
business and i think it's at that stage
is when we should be asking about access
it is about what's reasonable but i
think it's used too often as an excuse
not to do anything and we need to stop
doing that and i'd like trafford to be a
lead in
asking those questions and making sure
we get buildings that are accessible to
all our residents not
just some of them
okay thank you uh councillor minister
you want to come back in
i'm just gonna i i can absolutely
appreciate the um the the lift and i
mean if it would be it would be great if
that could be put in but um the thing is
obviously like um
uh scholly said that it's not there's
not a you know a
thing written in law that that you have
to have
the accessibility to every floor um
i imagine that that children with with
um different abilities may well be
be accommodated on the ground floor so
that would hopefully
you know go some way in terms of helping
that what i was going the other thing is
i'm going to say about the parking i can
see obviously there's a couple of spaces
on aren't you know very aren't easily to
get to the thing is people will
go by walking people will
go you know i i never drove my children
to nursery and they were commuting
children that came with me on the tram
um and in buggies so or buses when we
lived in manchester so
that that's not going to be i don't
think that is going to be a problem um i
think that you know if we i think i can
take the point with the accessibility
i'm still still going to be
um voting for it because i don't think
it's a reason to say no
um
and deferring i think does carry that
risk of non-determination so i just
thought just food for thought that's all
okay counselor understand me
uh thank you chair uh just to pick up on
counselor minister's point
um
this is about providing access to all
children and i know we've all got
experience of disability we've all got
experiences particularly
of children with disability i can't look
disabled children in the eye and said
you know what it's too hard mate it's
too hard you're like you'll have to go
in that classroom all your mates are
going upstairs you're going to have to
stay there i can't do that i can't in
all conscience i can't do that i don't
think that the people who are involved
in
nursery places want to do that which is
why i am not i am not proposing that we
turn this down i'm not proposing that at
all i am proposing we allow some time
for the very reasonable people sat there
to have a conversation with very
reasonable people sat there and work
something out because i'm telling you
now
looking at the layout of that an
absolute doddle it just takes a little
bit of time you can put a three-four
lift in your house for five grand
we're talking those sums of money the
conversation needs to take place i'm not
recommending we turn this down
absolutely no
are you willing to have a
okay do you think well i think that
that's
my apology chair okay cancer thomas
thank you uh without echoing councilman
stanley on that i fully agree what he
said
if we needed determination
again this is something i'm not really
minded to do
but if we need a uh some reason to
refuse this
the
the possibility of 32 vehicles turning
up
on this lane at that point at one point
in the morning is a massive loss of
immunity to
the
um residents on inglewood close
on hall lane notwithstanding that
although you can't see on the map there
to the rear of inglewood uh house your
mersey house and then you have the
caravan park which is
uh
where the lane goes where they're in the
process of building the houses now so
you can have massive construction there
massive construction vehicles people
parking there
it's a it's a lot of amazing personally
i think it's dangerous
okay thank you council thomas
councilman stanley i'm you so i'm sorry
for um
bringing you up on trying to engage with
the with the applicant but i think i
think in these circumstances it probably
would be useful because i think mr
massey was indicating he wanted to
contribute something on that is that
right okay mr masses
thank you jeff um just just speaking to
to the applicant we are willing to to
look at the exo accessibility issue i do
we do fully understand and appreciate
the situation now whether that is via a
stair lift with that we can look at or
you know we can challenge that first or
alternatively we can look at a three
floor stair lift which is something that
we're we're definitely willing to do if
there's some way of conditioning that
so that we we're doing best endeavors to
to to get the best possible solution for
this is something that my client is
willing to to to look at
but sorry just to just to just
given the situation with mrs roberts at
the moment you know the idea of
deferring the application further
another month is seriously damaging
damaging the the business
[Music]
thank you mr massey that's uh that's
that is very helpful um
can we do some condition on that
okay um
councillor uh
when stanley you pose the motion that we
defer so i mean the applicant was
i suppose it's whether you want to
persist in that motion to defer and
cancel our action you seconded that
that would be my preferred option i do
not want to damage their business i
don't want to damage their business i
don't want to stop the work on them but
i spent a life negotiating contracts and
i know that words like best endeavors i
know you know you don't mean it this way
they don't mean anything i know i know
you i i absolutely need
yeah so
the condition has to be worth it in such
a way that it's not used as a way of and
i trust you i trust you
as a way of not
trying to think of an alternative word
to weaseling i don't know easily after
this
that's fine yeah we could we can use a
negatively worded condition which is a a
requirement as opposed to a
please put something forward to us
okay so the requirement could be quite
strongly worded around the uh the
options which will be looked at
so there will be it will be to
to um allow accessibility to the first
floor oh
i think it would be unreasonable to
require the the um ability to access the
storage because that isn't
the public part of the building yeah
you're right um but certainly we can um
we can word a condition to require uh
access to the to the first floor in in
such a way that they put it they put a
scheme forward and uh
council caswell understand if there are
difficulties in that provision then um i
i can
i i would come to you and and tell you
about that okay i think i thought before
we signed anything off
okay so i'm happy to change my proposal
from deferral to acceptance with with
such a condition
okay
thank you
thank you councillor acton okay uh
councillor chalking with that heard from
you i don't know if you still want to
speak i thought we've
heard okay yeah thanks chad um
it's a hard one for me because i started
thinking
two things here one one i fully support
another nursery coming in and i have no
issue with that at all
um i do understand the concerns from
neighbours uh
about noise etc and concerns are being
raised here about um outdoor play space
it's not very big so for me
for 30 kids it's negative already
my main issue here is that i don't think
it's an appropriate location for the
site uh for the nursery you know council
thomas has already said that cancer
factors already mentioned that
you
for
one main reason and you've got a new
housing estate going around the back of
it um up to 400 homes at one point at
some point you're going we spoke two
meetings ago about thinking about
the everything that's going on in the
area when we're approving planning
applications so we need to consider it
and this is one of those moments i think
where actually you have to think is this
the right
location to have a nursery
with 30 kids who may be walking maybe
cycling will most likely be driven
um
with all the associated building works
going on traffic going up and down
there's only two roads in and out of
that new estate
is it appropriate that's so i'm sorry
thinking i can't actually support this
for that particular reason
uh council shocking are you
moving that we refuse permission
well i know if i i'm not gonna move to
refuse it but i'm gonna i'm not gonna
support the um application okay um
diagonal i think you were the only other
person i had who wants to speak again i
think
events have probably overtaken me a
little bit but i'd just like to
acknowledge that mr massey's
contribution i think it's really useful
to have those conversations
um
it isn't just about disabled children
it's about parents and carers who want
to see their children in the setting
where they spent the day those are the
conversations parents once have with
their children it isn't acceptable that
children might be um playing in a room
all day that the parents don't get to
see or they don't have those exchanges
for staff at the end of the day because
that conversation has to take place
away from the classroom so it is a
really important consideration
for a successful nursery place i
absolutely still have issues with the
outdoor play limitations and i assume
that that is because there was no
comment made outside our remit
no i mean if members wanted to move to
remove the conditions requiring the
limitations of outdoor play then then
they could do then they could do so
i personally would prefer that i don't
think um staggered playing outside with
that many children would be a bother to
anybody neighbors or otherwise but i do
think it would be
um i use the word crime
um
in inverted commas um that children were
not given access to play outdoors at any
time that they chose to do so and i i
don't understand why
you know i think that that puts a real
limit on the potential for for the
children
in their learning
going forward and we want the best for
our children you know i like i say i do
support the montessori approach i do
think partington needs some sort of you
know would benefit from this provision
which is slightly alternative to usual
provision from nurseries but i don't
think that that compromise is okay
i wouldn't want my children to be at a
nursery where they could only go out for
half an hour a day it is not victorian
england
so you're suggesting no condition at all
around that so 30 children could play
outside all day
i i agree with them counseling actually
but that wouldn't be the case there
wouldn't be 30 children out all day
there might be there was a fire alarm
but that would be the case anyway
it's just
sorry speak obviously
i just think it would be something that
the nursery could manage perfectly well
would want to manage anyway because they
would have um most nurseries have
you know
had to have a timetable i think it could
be managed quite well within the nursery
um
they are quite small children
maybe distance lends enchantment but i
don't remember mine being that noisy
give them a book outside sorry mr massa
do you want to um
do you want to address on that if uh
if you've got something useful to say
sorry jeff um yes i mean the the noise
report suggested that there was no
mitigation that was required um
the mitigations kind of come forward
through the discussions with the with
the planning officer and listening to
some of the the responses that come from
from the objections
i totally agree comments about about the
noise of the children we you know it is
an onerous condition but
you know we've got a situation with mrs
roberts that we're you know she really
wants to make this nursery succeed in
this location there's a huge opportunity
with 400 houses there
we can't change the location of the of
the building the building is where it is
uh we we think it's a perfectly suitable
uh location for the building understand
the issues over car parking if there's a
100 children in a in a nursery we're not
going to provide 100 car spaces on site
you know so i think the idea of
providing 30 car spaces for 30 children
i think is
difficult to say the least
with respect that's not what i said okay
no
counselor thomas let's leave it thank
you mr massey appreciate it appreciate
your comments but
no not at the moment now
um if if members wanted to move forward
with councillor dagnall's suggestion
um
and and i'd have no particular
particular objection to this we've we
followed our environmental health
officers um
suggestions on this rather than that
being a matter of strict strict planning
judgment then that would be the removal
of condition number nine
just to help move things along i've got
no objection to the proposal made by
councillor dagnan i'm sure the nursery
is perfectly capable of managing this
thing for itself
so i'm more than happy to support the
removal and second the removal of that
condition okay are any members uh
against removing that condition
no any members uh against the
condition around the left access anyone
want to speak against that
no okay
so um
so i think we can probably no one's
proposed a refusal uh i know you spoke
against councillor chalking but you've
not proposed that
so i think we can probably move to
develop i'd probably just say something
myself on this which is that i i think
it's a good site for nursery use
actually i think
there's bound to be demand for nursery
places given that housing that's being
built and what i would just say is that
you know we talk a lot about the
committee about the demand for school
places how we need to be more school
places but we do need early years and
nursery places we we you know we
definitely do and we need them in that
area and other areas across trafford
speaking to nursery owners in my own
ward the amount of care that
grandparents are providing as as halved
by their estimate
and you know i think nurse requires
change because i think i think the
drop-off from pick-up times are more
staggered now they like to be more
staggered because people are working
more flexible patterns more people are
working at home
i don't have a concern with the parking
because
you know frankly there are lots of day
nurseries around trafford that have no
parking whatsoever um so the question is
what's what's the impact on on the
highway there and i don't think it's
significant given we're talking about 30
children maximum and
and staggered sort of pick up and drop
off times
um
so you know i'm very supportive of the
application i think i think we need to
build that that capacity in early years
education and i think uh you know i'm
happy that
we changed the condition on the
the limit on the children playing
outside i think there is a condition
around
the boundary treatment isn't it which
would still which would still be in so
that would still offer some mitigation i
think against denoise
um so if members are happy i think we'll
vote on
the uh that the motion to
agree or officer recommendation
to grant but subject to removing
condition nine
and also um
coming up with appropriate conditions to
ensure the uh lift access is addressed
so let's vote on that then members uh in
favor of that please
okay anybody against
yeah okay
okay
so that motion is carried so
permission is granted subject to those
changes thank you
uh next application we'll look at is
number 105 975 11 to 13 raglan road so
that's on page 43 of the bundle that
we've got
we'll have an introduction first of all
from miss milner and we'll just wait for
people to to leave if they wish to
leave thank you
thank you chair so
the next application relates to
development at land at 11 to 13 ragnan
road in sale yeah this application site
is currently occupied by a large
victorian um villa known as ragland
house the property is in residential use
with 11 one-bedroom apartments
accommodated from the existing building
the site benefits from two separate
vehicle accesses from raglan road there
aren't currently no
formal parking areas and repair parking
taking place informally across um areas
of hard standing and grassed areas
ragland house is recognized as a
non-designated heritage asset with
historical and architectural
significance although the building is
currently in a poor state of repair and
there are a number of existing
inappropriate additions to the building
which detract from its visual appearance
planning permission is sought for the
redevelopment
of ragland house
and to provide a total of 14 apartments
therefore an uplift of three from the
existing situation together with the
erection of a detached apartment blocked
to the rear of
the site and comprising six apartments
totaling 20 altogether on site the
proposed new build will be three stories
including the lower ground floor and
will be served by the existing access
road and with
um the other the detached property
served by the other access
with basement and lower ground floor
apartments proposed within the existing
and new apartment box and excavation is
proposed throughout the site
objections have been received um
from eight different properties in
relation to residential amenity and
character in appearance trees ecology
highways parking and drainage and a lot
of support has been also received and
mentioned it would be a positive
development within the local area
renovating a building and bringing it
back into use
and importantly to note there is an
extant permission
and on the site for a two-story um
residential and flatted block in
similarly in in the location of the
proposed um
block to the rear of the site
and
this
proposed for two beds and has been
implemented and that has been
confirmed i said commenced that has been
confirmed by officers and therefore we
must give that substantial weight
um
the proposed extensions to the main
villa building are considered
subordinate to the main building in
height and position and are considered
appropriate in the context
on balance it's considered they
represent an overall improvement to the
existing situation
the new apartment block is also
considered appropriate in design and
scale to ragland house
never the ls we have identified moderate
harm to the non-designated heritage
asset and primarily resulting from the
loss of soft landscaping and the extent
of excavation around the site
and this is weighed in the planning
balance and we also give consideration
to the full back position of the
existing permission
whilst the prose development would
increase the number of residents
occupying the site it's considered that
this remains in an appropriate level
given the character of the area in the
relation
relation to the impact on neighboring
properties from overlooking and loss of
privacy
it is considered that the pros
development would not result
in such an impact so be harmful to
warrant refusal and all residential
units would comply with the nationally
prescribed space standards and it's
considered that the apartments would
receive
an acceptable level of daylight and
habitable room space
there is also an emergency space
provided in the form of terraces and
lawn areas the proposed parking and
accessory arrangements are considered
acceptable balancing the need for
parking and soft landscaping and the
impact that would have on the
non-designated heritage asset
the proposals have been amended during
the consideration of the application to
approve the appearance of the
alterations and extensions
and to improve their impacts on amenity
and i would like to draw members
attention to the additional information
report which proposes further drainage
conditions following um ongoing
discussions with the lead local flood
authority also we've clarified matters
or sort of clarify matters regarding
accessibility and we also wish to
increase the um the wording of
conditions six
and
thirteen and so that they provide and
they're more meaningful in in securing a
high quality scheme
the proposal is considered to be
acceptable in principle um whilst it
would and resulting in
harm and moderate harm to the
undesignated heritage asset we do give
substantial weight to the extent
position
permission and the provision of more
housing on site
and therefore the proposal is considered
to
comply with the development plan as a
whole and no adverse impacts are
identified that would significantly and
dramatically outweigh the benefits of
the scheme therefore recommending it for
approval um these are just cgi's so
obviously they always come with a health
warning about and they are just images
they're not um approved plans and just
for information this is the previously
approved site plan and if you know to
the
north of the uh
of the existing building you can see the
um outline of the approved and commenced
apartment block thank you
thank you miss miller is um mr adkins
with us
yeah
thank you mr redken if you just want to
have a seat and um
just bring the
microphone close to you so that we can
hear it and i think it's lit up there
yeah um mr atkins and you'll have four
minutes to speak to us thank you thank
you
good evening i speak on behalf of the
nine submitted objections we believe
there are nine not eight as was just
stated
from campbell and magnum roads and 59
signatories of a petition against the
development including residents at
almost every address on the two roads
we object on the following grounds
disregard of heritage objections
insufficient and unsafe parking
non-adherence of pg-1 distance
guidelines poor rain water management
and environmental impact and substandard
living conditions
one both the planning and heritage
development officers identified the lack
of detail regarding repair and
refurbishment of raglan house
there are plans to create additional
units within the main house as well as
demolition and replacement of extensions
it is unacceptable that the developer
has not provided any significant detail
in this regard especially as the site
and house have been identified as a
non-designated heritage asset with a
degree of significance meriting
consideration in planning decisions
we do not believe the developer has duly
considered the complexity of a
refurbishment which is too large a
project in its own right to be a
condition as a planning officer intends
two referring to point 73 of a report 21
parking spaces falls well short of a
required maximum of 35 and the lha have
also determined that the proposed
parking layout creates conflict points
lack of spaces will create additional
parking on raglan road which is already
congested lha comment that this could
have an impact on visibility servicing
and access to the site fire appliance
tracking provided shows that both sides
of the road would need to be free for
ingress
thus the additional on-street parking
will inhibit emergency access
a similar development of gains for a
house at five raglan road should set
local precedence with its provision of
20 parking spaces for 12 flats a
significantly higher ratio
clarification from the lha is still
required
number three boundary distances for a
two-story new build and extensions fall
short of the pg-1 section 11 guidelines
impacting our rights to light privacy
and quiet in neighboring properties
we emphasize that it is not one distance
but all distances around the new build
as well as between the new build and
raglan house that are too short
impacting all neighbours and future
occupants
under points 58 and 59 of the report the
interface distance between raglan house
and a new build is well short at 7.7
metres versus the 15 meters guideline
although considered similar to a
previous approval to a previous approval
this distance is further reduced and so
is not comparable
four the distance measurement from the
from the large soak away in the revised
below ground drainage plant is to an
approximately 0.5 meter alcove in the
new build and thus the actual distance
will be significantly less than the
required 5 meters
to build this soak away excavation work
close to retained trees including
third-party trees and within the drip
line of t-15 will be required
these works will cause tree root damage
not considered in the tree surveys
there are further concerns about
exacerbated surface flooding on raglan
road and new flood risk to basement
flats
should the drainage screen not be
approved by the llfa what impact will
this have on the development as a whole
five no significant work has started in
the six years since the 2016 approval
with minimal initial work in 2019 to
meet the letter of condition one but not
the spirit
further applications more similar to the
current proposal since this time have
all been declined or withdrawn the
unsightly boarding of trees wire fencing
scaffolding left up for months and poor
site maintenance since could be
considered a public nuisance under law
of tort
there is a cynical attempt here to get a
larger development through the back door
in summary the development only creates
an additional nine units six of which
are at basement level giving poor
lighting aspect and living conditions
notably this also does not include any
affordable housing
given the negative impact this will have
on a neighborhood and road traffic
safety it is not significant enough in
terms of a council meeting its housing
land supply to warrant approval
therefore we seek to have the planning
consent for this over development
declined
thank you thank you mr perkins uh is mr
mcmullen uh with us
oh yeah
mr mcmullen have you if you want to um
come to the front and then just make
sure you're close to the microphone so
we can hear you
and
you will have um three minutes to speak
to us and we'll start a timer once you
start talking thank you
it's okay yeah okay
uh good evening members my name is andy
mcmullen i'm the agent for the planning
application
the existing site is a large detached
victorian villa accommodating 11 one
bedroom departments
the building has grown over a number of
years creating additional accommodation
that is substandard and to the detriment
of the host building
this proposal therefore represents an
opportunity to reconfigure the entire
site providing a scheme that is in
keeping with the existing building and
provide residential accommodation that
meets current standards
the application follows extensive
discussions with the planning department
over a number of years
we first entered into pre-application
discussions with the council in august
2018 and then submitted an application
for 22 units
due to concerns at the time regarding
this scheme the application was
withdrawn
this application that is for
consideration today has sought to
address the previous comments and also
those expressed during this application
process
the key changes from the previously
withdrawn scheme are as follows
the extension to the rear is now
subservient to the main build building
and reduced in height by a story
number of redundant units has been
reduced from 22 to 20 so that's a net
increase of nine
we've amended the new build layout so it
is as close to the layout of the x-stamp
permission as possible
the general design and appearance of the
extensions are more in keeping with
ragland house
and finally the outdoor terraces have
been increased in size and retaining
walls reduced in height will allow views
out
and light into the basement levels
more specifically with regard to the
existing building the application
proposes the internal reconfiguration
part demolition and creation of 14
residential units that's an increase of
three the other part of the scheme is
the creation of the six residential
units in the new block to the rear of
the site on the same footprint and
height as the extant permission
in terms of the benefits of the scheme
these can be summarized as follows
more efficient use of an existing
residential site in a sustainable
location
removal of the 1970s and 1980s
extensions at the rear which distract
from the host building
with more modern
subservient additions the creation of 20
apartments that's a net increase of nine
we'll all meet
nationally described space standards to
replace the 11 existing apartments
and it would assist making a small but
important contribution to the council
shortages of housing in the borough in
summary we hope members will agree that
the proposal represents a significant
improvement both externally and
internally against what currently exists
on site and is a sensitive redevelopment
redevelopment proposal we hope you'll be
able to support the scheme thank you
thank you mr mullen
uh any members looking to
start our discussion on this
council understand me
uh thank you chad um i'm struggling a
little bit with this one um something
definitely needs to be changed on this
side because the existing site is a is a
complete mess as was summarized by the
um
one of the speakers there very very
unsympathetic i'm not sure this is the
scheme i'm not i'm not sure it is
um i'm really concerned about the
traffic there there's
22 parking spaces for 35 flats it's
already an area which suffers from um
horrendous traffic traffic problems
hence the lot tends the
currently being revised plans for a low
traffic neighborhood around the
um
i think the massing of the uh of the new
build will
detract from the the houses around there
though i'm conscious that the there
isn't already an extent planning
approval for for that
um
my
big concern is very similar to my
concerns with the last one is that we we
appear to be nodding through
again as a
building which is discriminatory and i
heard with great interest what um ms
coley said it on the um
on the last uh application on this but
we're about to allow
the
recommendation to allow planning
permission for a massive refurbishment
of an existing house
existing building where we put a lift in
it which is great but we're doing
nothing to address the fact that i think
there's four steps to get up to the
building there's no ramp in the in the
in
and we all know from all of the the
lovely um
the stuff that's been done around the
borough be very simple to build a ramp
into one of the access points into the
um into the main building
the new build and again i'm conscious of
already just in planning permission um
has level access but there's no there's
no lift in it
and it seems again if we don't
if we don't
address these issues at this stage in
um in development both refurbishments
as half of this is and the new bill
which other half is
it's criminal it's absolutely criminal
and again going that's what miss carlos
said i do think the the legislation is
there to to cover this because if we
allow this to happen it's discriminatory
and we have we have duties under several
sections of the psed to remove
discrimination we do so i think i think
the law is there i also final point and
and certainly based on the extremely
cooperative reaction the last applicant
i suspect if we had a conversation very
very conscious of directors through
through your chair if we had a
conversation with the applicants here
about this i don't think it'd be a very
difficult conversation
thank you chair
uh thank you counter action
um
uh again i agree with um some of the
stuff that barry uh council wins stanley
has said there about the new build
being built and designed without access
being
a consideration with bearing in mind
that this is going to be three floors
and i think
all new builds should
have access for everyone and i'll keep
saying that over and over again
um i'd like some clarity regarding the
car parking spaces
uh what's the minimum i heard it say 30
is 35 the minimum
i don't think there is a minimum is
there there's a maximum there's there's
only maximum standards
so there isn't a minimum this is just a
maximum so is it 21 car parking spaces
did did i hear it so
yes
um my other comment is um actually
looking at the design and i know
we don't know for definite it's just an
artist's impression but um considering
what's already there i think it's much
better and it's definitely much better
than the
10 and 11 story flats that we get
stopped within old trafford
um council thomas coming to your moment
i do think we need to temper our
language a little bit on this
application okay i think we can be
critical about the lack of accessibility
but i'm not happy with members using
phrases like criminal or discriminatory
okay so um i i think the point is well
made but i do think we need to attempt
our language and keep those
contributions uh
appropriate councillor thomas
thank you chad uh once again uh on the
accessibility issue
uh i completely agree what's been said
before me we're going forward on this
and this is the real shame of this there
are actually um
[Music]
representations from local neighbours
who um in favor of the
main house being
refurbed
and it's a shame that this cannot be
worked through
with them
the massing on the site
is
well over there's very very little green
amenity
uh for
what is potentially 58 59
residents living in in in the two blocks
the the second block and again
and not to the extent um
permissions there
number 15 is
severely overlooked number two campbell
is overlooked
the parking
is woefully inadequate
woefully inadequate for
the number of cars that are potentially
on the site
notwithstanding again as councilwoman
stanley mentioned this is a low traffic
neighborhood this is something where we
are trying to con
contain what is regarded as a rat run
the rat run will be um
will be stopped by i think is from from
when we were out recently it will be
stopped by uh one modal filters which
will direct everything onto marston road
which will make mars road which is
already a very very busy road
uh appalling
parking on roads 7 9 17
probably 21
19 21 23
could potentially be severely disrupted
by on street parking on a road that has
sleeping policeman and is not wide
enough to um
carry on street parking in my opinion so
as it stands this this the plan as it
stands i'm afraid i cannot agree with it
and i would propose to
go against
officer recommendation at this time
thank you councillor dagnol
um hi i know the area quite well i know
the house quite well i know the road and
the location quite well
i i really want to like this plan i i
really want
more
flats more homes more houses for people
locally it's very difficult for people
to buy houses locally um assuming that
some of these smaller flats would be
accessible in a accessible price bracket
for for younger people so i really
really want to like this plan um
but it just seems to me that there are
too many people on this site and that a
number of people
means that there is not enough parking
and
along with side with that there's too
much tarmac causing the issues that
we've seen mentioned several times
around um water runoff
um and just simply
the the amount of people squashed into
that space
creating the things that that many
people do create for example rubbish um
i noticed that there are some issues
about
rubbish collection and bin storage etc
which is understandable
and they are managed in
new builds in other places
because they are built into the design
but there is always compromise when you
are trying to preserve which i again i
completely respect
preserve the majority of this house and
its uh
and its nice architecture
but i just think it's it's too many
people on that site so would that come
under massing
i'm not sure is that the building
you you
over development thank you i feel like
it is over development for the site
and i really don't want to say that i
would very much like there to be some
more accessibly priced housing in that
area but at the moment i just think it's
too much
thank you council bunting
yeah i think thank you chairman i think
in this case we are perhaps letting the
letting the perfect become the enemy of
the good is this ideal no probably not
is it better than the alternative
most likely um
as we've already mentioned there is the
extant permission
i could just go ahead
you know build it to the to the rear and
then look to redevelop the main fun
building later maybe even level the
front building later and that would be
a far more serious impact upon the non
uh designated asset than the existing uh
proposals that's for sure
uh if i think we've struggled with this
snow for a number of years um
something needs to be done with it
because the building is in a
increasingly poor state of repair and if
it's allowed to carry on too much longer
then that may become terminal
in terms of the building to the rear in
terms of access yes it would be lovely
if you could ever lift in the uh
or stair lifts or whatever it would be
uh but the extent times we shouldn't go
ahead as is so that option trying to
insist on that is going to be very
difficult i know mrs curley has pointed
out and previously have to make due
consideration but there is no
requirement for a lift specifically in
terms of the main building i think a
lift could be far more difficult time to
you know get one into a very old
building like that that could be more
difficult
uh but as i say you may not have to
worry about that too much longer because
the building could be replaced with a
new one uh which would be far less
pleasant to look at than a revamped
version of that which is there
so whilst i
accept to the points about the uh over
development i guess there is it says
heavy development on this site and it
would be lovely to see something else
that's we can't wish
it's not yeah not the committee of
wishes
we can't just fantasize about what we'd
like to see on this site we have to
accept that which is there and that was
his extant and look at the proposal and
try and come to a make a reasonable
decision based on that
parking is not ideal either yes there
will there may be some on street parking
although i don't believe enough to cause
a
well to justify a refusal
uh although it's not ideal again it's
perhaps better than the alternative if
the new build is put there
uh and again distance wise same problems
you already got the extend permission uh
so the extent of michigan score as it is
and that'll be i believe worse than this
proposal
so
given all those caveats and with a
significant lack of enthusiasm
uh i think this is perhaps
the best of a bad deal
uh and therefore i'm happy to go along
with officer recommendation and as soon
as no one's proposed anything yet i'll
propose that we do just that thank you
gentlemen
thank you council bunsen can i um
just check the the lift and
accessibility situation so my
understanding is the
the original old building
there will be a lift but there won't be
level access
and in the new building
there will be level access but but no
left yeah correct
sorry chairman old age
no i i wasn't 100 sure myself dory um
any other members looking to speak
just to reply very briefly to council
bunting and with the greatest respect it
isn't an all-or-nothing situation the
amount of homes planned for that site
could be reduced which would have a
knocking effect which would improve the
situation both for people who live there
in the future and for neighbours because
it would reduce the amount of parking
required
and the amount of rubbish produced and
the amount of people who lived in a
small space so there is a there is a way
forward um that doesn't mean
um no development and the end of this
building um
that there are compromises that could
and perhaps should be made so um
i i understand what you're saying and
like i say i do have some sympathy with
the development of this site you know
it's basically
a perfect place to make a development
it's just that i believe that this one
is too large
thank you councillor
morgan thank you chair i can i can
honestly understand a lot of the
comments that were made but i i'm going
to be voting in favor of this
application now or second councilor
bunting's proposal um
i just don't think there are planning
reasons to reject this um um i i i need
to go through
there's the existing the existing
building i do actually share um cancer
with stanley's point but there is
already the existing permission so i
don't think there is a reason to reject
it on the basis of it not having a lift
um for the new for the new building um
for parking i i i i mean i voted against
things in the past because of not lack
of parking but i don't think there is a
such a lack of parking to reject it on
on this one um
and
um
i i probably don't think it's an
overdevelopment that's probably that's a
judgment call you know someone else
might have a very different view um i'm
i mean i i i am staggered that this this
house is actually occupied at the moment
in the condition it's in
um
um
so um
i think in
tilted balance and
my judgment is that this is um there
isn't planning reasons to reject it but
i know others will um have a different
opinion um but um thank you
thank you councillor uh councilman i'll
come back to you
yes uh thank you chair i just realized
that no one's second the refusal of
of this
um so i'll second
uh
counter thompson refusing this but i
want to add an extra reason for refusal
um i think your job development
i'll add that with the council is
failing under it's due duty under the
public sector equality duty is laid out
on page 37 we're not eliminating
discrimination we're not about quality
opportunity and we're not fostering
fostering good relations between persons
protective characteristic
so i don't think that's a planning
reason to refuse
would be uh then add confusion as to why
it's mentioned in the planning report
there's a difference between planning
policy and the public sector equality
duty you can determine that you're not
discharging your public sector equality
duty and decide that you um don't want
to move the application forward but to
refuse the application has to be on the
grounds that it does not provide
appropriate
accommodation for for
or accessible accessibility
for those with a disability but you
wouldn't a planning reason for refusal
is not
not not discharging the public sector
equality duty that would be muddling the
two bits of legislation up
so i'm going to confuse which section of
the act of accessibility can we include
in the in the refusal of the
it would be under policy l7 which
requires um the uh ex
accessibility to to new developments
we don't have a policy you know we've
not really got a leg to stand on yeah of
course a question is a cause of great
frustration to me we reckon that we have
yeah but great frustration but we would
have to
um
but we would have to frame it in
planning policy terms not in public
sector equality duty terms refresh it in
whichever way is yeah obviously and
that's why we could we experience you're
there maximum but not planning all but i
think it's important because this will
come back again
it's important that it's in there so
that when the plans come back again the
developer knows what we're going to
we're going to be talking to them about
this okay brilliant thank you chair
thank you cancer welton
thank you um yeah i'm very divided on
this but i think i'm uh persuaded by
councillor um bunting and councillor
morgan that this is a uh
uh maybe at least worst option for the
for the site i'm certainly not
not too worried about the the level of
parking um partly because it's a very
accessible area this is a there's a
reasonable wealth of um of
public transport links uh and yes it is
um hopefully going to become a low
traffic neighborhood but that is there
to actually encourage people to walk in
cycles so they don't actually need
recourse to their car um and that should
help um you know and these will be these
are small properties hopefully there
will be starter homes they're more more
likely than not be occupied by people
who have um one car
um or hopefully no cars at all as we
improve the um you know the public
transport and active travel provision in
the area um going forward
um and hopefully
sometime maybe a car club as well when
we finally get those approved in the um
you know in our borough um so i
certainly won't be uh objecting to on
those grounds um and i think
that i'll finish that thank you
thank you councillor welton uh
i think like for myself like you i'm i'm
generally supportive of the application
it's it's not without reservations but i
don't think those reservations are
significant uh you know significant
adverse impacts there where the benefits
because this is a tilted balance
application and
like you i'm not really concerned about
the parking actually we've approved
other residential accommodation with you
know with less uh
less parking per per resident or per
per unit certainly and
it's a highly sustainable location low
traffic neighborhood ideally will be
reducing car ownership so
i'm not so concerned about that i'm
going to diagonal sorry
briefly i know i've been a bit of a
nuisance tonight and asked lots of
questions will the car parking be
allocated to the properties
will people move into that into that
block with the expectation that there is
somewhere to park the car or will some
people understand that there is no
parking when they when they buy or rent
the properties in the future
we've not um we don't have that level of
detail from the application but we do
have a travel plan condition so it might
be included within that yeah it just
seems to me that it would be helpful if
people understood the situation when
they were looking at either renting or
buying there and would help residents um
by reducing the number of traffic
vehicles obliged to park on the street
um because anybody who drove along there
would see that it wasn't a particularly
great option for them so that's
interesting thank you very much thank
you thank you okay it's been moving a
sec
any is it a new point councilman stanley
okay
it's um
it's it's very similar to the to the
last point that sorry the problem we
made on the last
on the last planning application
is
it's a it's a
condition if the if this is approved and
the condition is similar to the
condition we put into the last one to
sort out the
access
um
to both blocks
and i'm going to direct this to you
chair
to ask the question for the developers
still sat in the room
are they willing to have that
conversation with the planning team to
come up with an acceptable
solution does that make sense
so if this is a condition if this is
approved similar to the condition we put
onto the the last one
make sense
it does but the circumstances are
different aren't they because there's
already a lift in the existing building
and there's already level access so it'd
be
it'll be a more
complicated discussion i'd suggest well
actually it's a it's a simpler
discussion in terms of the old one
because to put her
ramped access into the old building
across 47 p when the in the in the i'm
sorry i exaggerated the same effect in
the context of the development they're
doing here it's a again it's an absolute
dot
make sense
yeah it it it does but i do think the
circumstances are different here because
it's it's also a
non-designated heritage asset isn't it
so we can't
that that is a factor in the balance
preserving the the the nature of the
non-destination heritage asset
absolutely no i i i totally understand
that but i don't see how
it's a non-designated heritage asset
it's not it's not listed it's a
non-designated heritage asset so again
it's the conversation to say how can we
change this in such a sympathetic way
and i went to that building yesterday
and you could do this very very easily
look at some of the great stuff that's
been done in a null trigger you could do
this really easily and it would make no
difference to the look of the building
and i'm sure the developer if we ask
them still here we'll just say yes
you're asking them through a condition
to carry out a building operation
that isn't on the plans
um
whereas with the last one it was an
internal operation so that was easier
i mean
so what about the the new build can't we
do it for the new build then isn't that
the same situation as the last one
again the new build might require a
leftover run we don't know so it's again
it's an amendment there could be an
amendment to the scheme
ask them
mr mcmullen i think it is
so i mean is this something you'd be
willing to agree to that we
we crafted conditions to
ensure level access to the old building
and a lifting in new building are you in
a position to
agree to that tonight
well i'm not i'm not the developer
i'm the planning consultant so i'd need
to take instructions for that just just
a couple of
points
um on that
i must admit the application's been in
for i don't know six six seven months if
if we'd known that was
such a concern to members i'm sure the
applicant would have looked looked at
that probably five months ago
a requirement for that
what we've always been told by the and
obviously we had dialogue with the
council's um conservation officer
throughout this process and
on balance this
this was considered acceptable this
proposal but we were always told that
that entrance which is uh obviously one
of the
the nicest features was
one of the nicest features on the site
but
i'm sure i can go back to them and you
know uh the applicant can ask
unfortunately they're not in the room
today but i could ask them the question
um they i think they
the ranked access or some sort of access
to the existing build the historic
building if you want to call that it's
i would have thought logistically having
been there a number of times it's it's
not a problem at all but it's it's the
heritage impact
that that would create
in terms of the
new build
um i think that would be more
problematic in terms of
because
the ramp is kind of separate it's you
know it's standalone it has no impact on
what's what's before you today obviously
putting an internal lift in
um i think that would
require greater discussion just because
it would obviously affect the layout of
the of the scheme that's been designed
and it's been designed very specifically
to the um x-stamp permission using those
restrictions so that would probably be
more problematic or default the existing
building less problematic but it creates
its own implications in terms of
heritage
okay thank you
uh so it was moving the second that we
refused permission by council thompson
council win stanley do you still want us
to
vote on that motion because i think
[Music]
so yeah i think i think if um if that's
still proposing seconded we would need
the the reasons that you're proposing
for that
yeah yeah
i've i've heard two reasons and i'm not
sure whether i've heard a third proposed
or not
that's come through the proposal so from
council thomas i heard um the
insufficient parking which would have a
detrimental impact on the immunity of
surrounding properties through on-street
parking i didn't hear you mention
highway safety counsellor
um
that's intrinsic i would say that's
intrinsic fine okay i did want to check
that um and from council win stanley i
heard that the development would not
make sufficient um provision for those
with a disability to access all parts of
the development um so
um
that's what i heard from the from the
two that proposed and seconded from
council dagnall i heard over development
but nobody really took
that further i said massin which
returned to be over development
you did yes okay thank you that's why i
wanted to make sure so massing and over
development
okay we'll we'll vote on that motion to
refuse then to refuse planning
permission so all those in favor of
refusal of you could indicate now please
and all those against refusal
um
so that motion is is is not carried
out
so yeah we'll move to the vote on
whether to grant planning permission uh
no so councilor understand me
are we
including in that the
um
something around the accessibility
we've i mean i know you've proposed that
i suppose i didn't propose that yeah i'm
i'm i'm conscious and i'm um
i'm conscious of an apology through the
chair to the um to the uh
i'm sorry i can't wait to the developer
if the conversation had taken place six
months ago they'd have done this already
they would have done it absolutely would
have done it
and that's they've done it
they're not stupid they're developers
they're business people they're not
gonna they're not gonna
pick a fight over something which would
be easy to build into the original plans
they've done it
i don't think it's fair to punish them
now
on the
the new building to insist on a lift but
they're very willing to make a part of
the condition of approval just heard
them
is to sort out the ramped access into
the
into the refurbishment so i'm happy
uh if we can
if people will support me in this to put
her a
condition in the
if it's approved that the ramped access
will be sorted out on the
old build that was a very complicated
way of saying that i think but i think
it's clear clear in the end
yeah
okay so uh your suggestion councilwoman
stanley and i'm looking for someone to
second this is that
we have a condition in the in the
approval
that level access is provided to the old
existing building but whatever yeah not
level access i don't think they can do
that it's it's
actually to make it accessible
what i would say on that is that um
that does have an impact on the heritage
nature of the building
yeah that is something we need to weigh
in the balance so um
and that's not something that we've
we've discussed we've obviously
discussed the heritage aspects but we
haven't discussed it in the context of
there'll be a ramp installed somewhere
around the building
uh councillor hassan has had to leave
due to pain from
a injury that is sustained today he's
just to let you know he's left the
meeting thank you cancer thomas
trump
to maintain the um and make it
worthwhile and to have a use going
forward
and i think probably accessibility is
trump's heritage here it could be
i mean imagine
very far away
okay
anybody against that proposal
[Music]
i think you can do it as long as you you
have considered the heritage impacts
that then then you will have because
you've got to remember you've got a
statutory duty under planning this to
build these conservation areas as well
although the non-designated heritage is
just in the balance
okay so we'll vote on the proposal to
grant permission
uh with the proviso that has a
conditioning about ensuring ramp taxes
to the existing building
uh so that's probably voting on all this
in favor of that proposal please
[Music]
okay
all those uh against that proposal
[Music]
okay
okay that is um so that's carried so i
think um
yeah
i've got april
four yeah
let's do it again i was in favor of
granting permission please
okay okay so that's kerry commissions
granted to that stat proviso we'll move
on now to the uh next application
uh on the list which is
uh
number 106 557 10 malad green in broad
heath and we've got a presentation from
mrday
any length of time
in the audience
[Music]
that's a written statement so he's not
the
here
[Music]
okay uh let's
carry on with mallard green then mr dave
could do the
presentation thank you chair um
this application has been reported to
the planning and demand management
committee as more than six letters of
objection have been received contrary to
the officer recommendation
the application relates to an l-shaped
plot
which is currently occupied by an end of
terrace
two-story dwelling with an attached
garage to the side and the single-story
rear extension
the plot includes a large garden which
wraps around the rear of the adjacent
car parking area
planning permission is sought for the
direction of a two-story two-bedroom
dwelling
which would have joined the existing
drawing
plus the erection of two semi-detached
double garages for the existing and
proposed dwellings
eight letters of objection uh from seven
individual addresses are being received
in relation to this application the
concerns raised are in relation to
design and appearance
residential immunity including
overlooking loss of light
highway safety ecology noise and
disturbance right of access use of
prevalent premises and covenants
the council fees
raise no objections to the proposed
development signature number conditions
there is an extent permission for a part
single part two story side extension
and single story rear extension which is
of a similar size and design to the
current proposed dwelling
um as such this forms a material
consideration
as the application proposes a new
dwelling and the council does not
currently have a five-year supply of
housing land the tilted balance is
engaged
it is considered the first development
will be acceptable in terms of design
and visual immunity and impact on
residential immunity highway safety and
biodiversity
subject to conditions the proposal would
therefore not result in any adverse
impacts that would significantly
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
the scheme
as such the development cause of the
development plan and is recommended for
approval subject conditions
thank you mr d is andrea d with us
please yeah if you want to come up to
the microphone and then
and just have a seat which bring the
microphone close to you
and you're speaking against this
application i understand so
you'll have three minutes once you start
speaking thank you okay thank you um i'm
andrew d i live at 11 mallard green of
which the proposed house will look onto
the side
of my house
i already have the windows of
the existing house um looking onto my
property and indeed me looking into
theirs so the addition of
another household looking onto onto my
house
isn't great bearing in mind this is four
and a half meters from my house there is
a single track between us which is the
access to the shared parking
which
is it is also an issue based on work has
already started on clearing landscape
and damage to my property has already
occurred
so
the the gap between the houses isn't big
enough for the building work and the
building traffic let alone
anything else
i also raised issues on the safety of
the fact that the the doorway
of this property faces comes out into
that driveway and literally there is a
paving slab
on each side of the driveway
of the access road so from that point of
view there is a safety issue as well i
appreciate the pact does also state that
it's my landing and stairway windows
they're looking into these properties
but it's still part of my house
and obviously a two-story building does
impact the view out of that window two
months ago i had a view over the garage
and some trees now i have
no the no trees that used to block sound
and the view of all the new build that's
happened with apartments and houses over
the other side of the road broadhead has
already had a lot of housing already
built
um it seems that we're just trying to
squeeze another house in where a garage
is
so uh from that so
from that perspective um
i would like this um rejected
we also have the share shared parking
and i appreciate that there's garages
being built and everyone's talks about
how useful that is um again that would
increase the traffic going into the car
park
and it also um
the allocation of the parking and
garages that we have
currently people can park in front of
garages
that wouldn't um with where the where
the garages are currently planned to be
that would mean that um at least one of
my neighbours is impacted by that and
wouldn't be able to do that
we've also
raised about
use of commercial use of garages and
this is because one of the one of the
houses in the clothes has sold the
garage space
and that is being used for business
purposes for storage um and again that
increases
the traffic into that car park because
it isn't just one person or one
household accessing it
so um they're in as
they were the main concerns i know that
there is also a um planning permission
originally raised and i'm currently
complaining about that as i was not
consulted
thank you thank you for coming uh is mr
mclaughlin here
yeah you want to come up to the um to
the seat just have a seat and bring the
microphone closer to you please
thank you so you'll have um three
minutes to speak to us we'll start the
clock once you start talking okay thank
you very much um my name is jim
mclaughlin
i'm the applicant for the planning at
mallard
we've already submitted answers to an
awful lot of the objections but um i
thought i'd like to just say a few words
as i think a lot of the objections
are very unfair especially with regards
to the parking
we're adding parking
on our own land
we have no we put in pictures from
nearly a week showing the car parking
area
isn't used the only car in the six days
that was there
is number 10 my tenant so
that car will be moved on to our parking
and we do have a grant of easement
access across
the car park um
the intended house isn't much bigger
than the uh
already existing planning for a
two-story extension
um
when we bought the property the car park
was used as a dumping ground now i'll
admit mainly by the people i bought the
property from
but it took me two skips and a lot of
work to clear the site myself
all the fencing was broken and fallen
down people were using the
land we plan to put the garages on for
dumping so we put new fencing up
we cleared that site as well
the trees that were existing we were
told by the people we bought it from
were very damaged the roots were exposed
as they were built on
a high piece of ground which was just
waste land from the original excavation
we had them checked for any
any birds or any bats nests there was no
sign of them there was no treasure tree
preservation order on anything all we've
done is added to the site we're not
we're not taking anything away the house
when it's done
will be rented out i have no intention
of selling it
rent it out to a local family that needs
somewhere to live the same as the house
that's there now is already rented to a
local family that needed somewhere to
live
it's below my way below market value i
look after the properties myself i'm
starting to retire now and can spend
more time making sure everything is kept
perfectly we will if we are granted
permission
make sure that everything we consult the
neighbors that everybody is taking into
consideration and the ground will be
landscaped as well when we're done
thank you thank you very much mr
mclaughlin any members looking to speak
on this item counselor thomas
thank you chair um
a very quirky uh application in in terms
of shape
um and i quite like it i i listen to the
resident and
whilst i feel her concerns and looking
through the representations we received
the the only real
um
issue i may have is that the double
garages are used for parking rather than
uh
any form of commercial activity
uh i would agree that uh
if they're going to make two-gallon
suitable garages out there they should
be used for what they are intended and
as part of
the applicant's
submission there it is around about uh
keeping
the the close safe and not
usurping car parking spaces from other
allocated houses so on that i'm quite
happy to propose that we
accept the recommendation to grant
you council thomas any other members
looking to speak
uh councillor bunting thank you
very little to add chairman but just
help me move matters on more than happy
to second the proposal just made a
moment or two ago
thank you any other members looking to
speak on this item
okay it's been moving seconded that we
uh grant planning permission we agree
officer recommendation all those in
favor of that recommendation
okay and anybody against
nope
okay um sorry councillor axton did you
sorry chancellor acton and cancer the
dagon should have said you both of you
came in afterwards started the item so
um so you can't vote on this item sorry
so let's do that again um so
i can't see how much it's because
i read what he was saying anyway
well you missed you missed part of the
presentation and that's what we've done
with previous items so
um all those uh in in favor of granting
planning permission if you could raise
your hands again
yeah thank you okay so that's permission
is granted and that concludes the item
so
i apologize to those people have been
waiting councillor young and other
speakers i'm afraid we're not going to
be able to deal with any more items
tonight because it's gone past half past
nine
so apologies that you've been waiting
all evening we'll have to defer those
items to
another meeting and we'll arrange for
that to take place as soon as we can
okay i apologize
at that point i'll close the meeting
thank you
members could just just stay so we can
agree date now is that okay thank you
so sorry the meetings the meeting's
still open until we agree dave so sorry
yeah councillor thomas bear with us
so uh
yeah next week it's probably going to be
difficult isn't it
we we have monday and thursday and i've
got uh public protection tuesday so
last week for me is how if it's okay for
others
yeah
i can only do
tuesday
wednesday what's what's the
produces public protection yeah
so wednesday
i can't do wednesday but maybe everybody
else can
let's use this public protection isn't
it it's tuesday public protection yeah
how many have we got across the team who
who can't make tuesday
[Music]
we can i do feel somewhat sorry for the
people who've sat here all evening um
and because they were already deferred
from april
um
i didn't
this is the longest committee i've ever
experienced
about 10 minutes
there's the chairs right here
so who uh
who who can't make wednesday who can't i
can't wait wednesday
i sure already okay
[Music]
what times your agent start could we
meet before your atm
seven is seven
as well
um
[Music]
is
is
i think it's going to be
5 30 5 30 1 evening next week
foreign
[Music]
is
is there anybody is there anybody else
apart from
okay can we let's try and get the states
halted
is that we're still in we're still in
the meeting and so we're still recording
okay so we're still on the stream okay
anybody apart from councillor morgan who
can't
uh who couldn't do 5 30 one evening next
week
okay twin uh
23rd of may we're looking at that 23rd
of may
that's a monday at six o'clock
so you can't make it can't you like an
hour
[Music]
okay i think we'll go with that then
yeah monday the 20th six o'clock monday
23rd
yeah so i think uh we'll have to go with
that i think most of us are available
that time and it's before the agm
monday 23rd we'll close the meeting
there okay
thank you